[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat en direct du salon de
l'agriculture qui ouvrira ses portes au
public dans une demi-heure et public
sénat installe son plateau au coeur de
ce salon pendant toute la semaine pour
vous faire vivre les temps forts les
coulisses les visites politiques qui
seront nombreuses
mais aussi pour débattre autour des
sujets agricoles et mieux comprendre le
métier d'agriculteur est le temps fort
de cette première journée c'est bien sûr
la visite du président de la république
emmanuel macron qui vient inaugurer ce
salon de l'agriculture il arrivera ici
porte de versailles dans quelques
minutes le chef de l'état qui commencera
sa visite par un discours sur l'europe
agricole à 3 mois maintenant des
européennes
il s'exprimera devant 500 personnes des
agriculteurs mais aussi des jeunes venus
de toute l'europe
nous suivons bien sûr ce discours en
direct et en intégralité sur notre
antenne dans quelques minutes et pour
nous permettre de suivre cette visite du
président de la république nos deux
journalistes quand un chalmé et tran huy
bonjour à tous les deux quentin calmez
vous êtes vous devant l'entrée de ce
salon de l'agriculture une inauguration
quentin qui coïncide avec une 15ème
journée de mobilisation des gilet jaune
est-ce qu'ils sont déjà présents devant
le salon canton et bien c'est
effectivement la question au regard d'un
quelle mobilisation pour les gilet jaune
ici au salon de l'agriculture nous
venons de rencontrer de croiser eric
drouet qui étaient là dès 8 heures pour
venir acheter un son billet pour aller
visiter le salon de la culture nous a
même dit qu'il allait manger du
saucisson
c'est ce qu'il nous a expliqué il nous a
pas dit plus de détails sur ce qu'ils
allaient faire exactement après mais
effectivement cela a fait monter à la
pression d'un cran à l'entrée du salon
puisqu'il a été immédiatement contrôlé
par des policiers on lui a contrôlé sa
pièce d'identité
et effectivement on a pu parler avec
quelqu'un de la préfecture de police de
paris qui nous a confirmé que
effectivement le dispositif de sécurité
était conséquent mais pas plus de
précisions sur le nombre de gendarmes et
de policiers mobilisés on attend de voir
maintenant combien de gilet jaune seront
présents on vient tout juste
voir deux ou trois gilet jaune en filets
à leur chasuble juste derrière moi merci
beaucoup quand on revient bien sûr vers
vous un poursuivre cette mobilisation
des gilets jaunes et l'accueil qui sera
réservé au président de la république
mais on va tout de suite retrouvé à tam
tran huy rebonjour table vous êtes vous
dans le hall où emmanuel macron va
prononcer son discours dans quelques
minutes là où il va donc commencer sa
visite
et cette visite à mes biens elles
s'annoncent longues très longues
effectivement oriane on nous annonce une
véritable journée marathon aujourd'hui
le président de la république doit
arriver d'un instant à l'autre
olemps dans ce hall principal où je me
trouve actuellement il doit être
accompagné du ministre de l'agriculture
didier guillaume puis faire un discours
ce matin devant 500 personnes pour
moitié de jeunes agriculteurs européens
avec un message l'avenir du secteur
agricole français passe par une
politique agricole commune forte une
europe forte sur ce sujet puis le
président de la république va se lancer
dans une longue déambulation dans les
allées du salon avec bien sûr et bien le
passage obligé
l'égérie du salon imminente cette vache
de race bleue du nord puis il doit aller
voir tous les acteurs de toutes les
filières ceux du lait de la filière
bovine de la volaille du porc d eux ça
c'est pour ce matin et puis cet
après-midi ce sera le tour de la
viticulture des fruits et légumes des
céréales et cetera il ne se dérobera à
aucune question nous dit-on dans son
entourage a aucun contact aucune
interpellation nous dit on lui qui est
devenu un spécialiste un des débats au
long cours depuis ces dernières semaines
pourrait battre un nouveau record de
présence on nous annonce son départ
seulement vers 22 heures
ce qui veut dire une visite d'environ 14
heures 2h 12 2 heures de plus que
l'année dernière
merci ta main et la journée s'annonce
longue pour vous aussi on vous retrouve
bien sûr tout au long de cette édition
pour les réactions politiques à votre
micro et pour nous accompagner sur ce
plateau tout au long de cette édition
spéciale nous permettre de comprendre
les enjeux de la visite du président de
la république et décrypter son discours
trois invités que j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir patrick martin jonnier
bonjour bonjour vous êtes un spécialiste
des affaires européennes auteur de ce
livre l'europe at elle un avenir 7 aux
éditions studyrama merci d'être avec
nous ce matin bruno parmentier bonjour
vous êtes consultant sur les questions
d'agriculture et d'alimentation et vous
êtes créateur du blog nourrir manger
point fr merci également d'être avec
nous et puis marcelo baez fred que nous
avons l'habitude de voir le matin sur
notre antenne bonjour marcelo
journaliste politique au figaro on va
commencer avec vous marcelo ans
puisqu'on a vu un emmanuel macron
arrivera dans quelques minutes
on l'a vu avec comptant dans un contexte
particulier forcément pour le chef de
l'état
aujourd'hui 15e journée de mobilisation
des gilet jaune oui on se souvient que
l'an dernier il avait été le présent la
république
hué à certains moments mais c'était une
colère du monde à l'école c'était des
préoccupations sur le glyphosate sur le
ceta sur le mercosur
cette fois ci le contexte est
complètement différent et quentin tout à
l'heure nous racontait qu'il avait
croisé le lite l'un l'une des figures
des gilets jaunes eric drew est prêt ici
à rentrer parmi les premiers on voit
bien que le risque du traquenard est là
et on sait que l'elysée est extrêmement
inquiet c'est peut-être pour ça que le
programme précis du chef de l'état n'a
été communiquée que très tardivement
les professionnels ne savais pas à quel
moment le président allait passer sur
leurs stands
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça que ce
matin il a prévu un format inédit avec
un discours d'une heure et d'une heure
et demie qui permet on va dire de
s'exprimer devant un parterre de gens un
peu quand même triés sur le volet donc
de sécuriser d'une certaine façon une
partie de sa journée avant de se jeter
dans le grand bain sans fil est ce sera
le reste de la journée
patrick matin jeunes et on va revenir
sur le fond de ce discours dont parlait
à l'instant marcelo consacré à l'europe
agricole mais d'abord un mot sur le
contexte
marcelo le disais il ne sera pas
question que d'agriculture aujourd'hui
pour le chef de l'état n'ont en effet il
va rencontrer des jeunes des jeunes
agriculteurs mais le fait qu'il
rencontre des jeunes agriculteurs de
l'ensemble de l'union européenne c'est
tout à fait symbolique est important car
il ya le contexte des difficultés
sociales les agriculteurs connaissent
également des difficultés sociales en
termes de revenus on va en parler tout
au long de cette matinée
mais nous sommes dans un contexte
d'élections au parlement européen et
vous connaissez aujourd'hui le contexte
politique à savoir la montée des
populismes et des nationalismes qui vont
pouvoir avoir un appât
sur donc le futur parlement européen il
faut savoir une chose c'est que la
politique agricole commune par
définition elle est européenne ce qui
veut dire que le parlement européen vote
également sur cette politique agricole
commune et le parlement qui va sortir
des élections du 26 mai aura un rôle
très important notamment sur l'adoption
du budget pour la prochaine période 2021
et 2027
on va revenir sur sur toutes ces
questions que vous le disais l'europe
agricole c'est le thème du discours d'
emmanuel macron mais bruno parmentier
sur ce contexte ce mouvement d gilet
jaune c'est vrai que c'est un mouvement
qui à peu pris on al'impression
finalement dans la france agricole chez
les agriculteurs comment vous
l'expliquez mais les agriculteurs un
énorme problème d'européens
ils ont à la fois un problème de revenus
et un énorme problème de changement
complet de leurs techniques de
production pour les éleveurs la
consommation de viande et de lait a
commencé à baisser et elle ne va cesser
de baisser pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années on va revenir à des
consommations beaucoup plus raisonnable
si j'ose dire et donc faut passer d'un
système tourné vers la quantité un
système tourné vers la qualité c'est
très difficile ils ont besoin d'être
aidés et pour les gens qui font d'eux
des légumes des céréales etc
il faut passer d'une agriculture
majoritairement chimiques pétrole chimie
tracteur à une agriculture
majoritairement écologique bon à des
symboles c'est il faudra arriver à se
passer de glyphosate mais encore plus
important il faut arriver à ne plus
jamais la bourre et or ne pas labourer
et ne pas avoir de produits chimiques
c'est très compliqué c'est une
révolution technologique majeure et donc
ils sont à la fois fragilisée par des
revenus faibles et devant une
modification complète de leur travail au
moment même où à peu près la moitié des
agriculteurs vont partir en retraite
dans les dix années qui viennent donc
c'est un choix de parler à des jeunes il
faut absolument trouver des jeunes qui
prennent le relais et qui construisent
l'agriculture du 21ème siècle qui va
être très différente de celle du 20e
mais pour revenir à ma question sur ce
mouvement d gilet jaune parce que si on
vous entend les
sculpteur aussi ont des problèmes et on
le sait notamment des problèmes de
revenus de rémunération alors du coup
comment vous expliquez que ce mouvement
n'est pas prêt qu'il n'ait pas rejoint
les gilet jaune
est-ce que vous l'expliquer peut-être
par le fait que le monde agricole est
encore un nombre très syndiqués ben oui
parce que le problème c'est pas leur
venue en soit c'est concrètement à
combien on leur achète leur récolte est
en fait les patrons là dessus c'est la
grande distribution savait que lille
quatre acheteurs qui achète 80 % de la
nourriture en france donc le rapport de
forces est extrêmement désavantageux et
donc bas tous les débats qui a eu depuis
un an et demi c'est dire comment se
répartit autrement la valeur comment les
français dépensent plus pour leur
alimentation pour soutenir leur
agriculture
et comment en effectue le partage de
valeurs dans un système de très grandes
inégalités des forces et donc en fait
leur problème c'est ça c'est est ce que
la grande distribution va leur laisser
plus de revenus oui vous êtes tout à
fait sous raison de souligner les
difficultés en termes de revenus le
revenu moyen d'un agriculteur c'est 1250
euros et encore il a beaucoup qui
touchent moins de 400 euros général
voilà donc ils sont quand même dans une
situation sociale financière extrêmement
fragilisée il y aussi des menaces sur la
future politique agricole commune donc
il ya des points communs entre les
gilets jaunes et les agriculteurs
simplement faut savoir qu'en trente ans
la part des agriculteurs dans la
population active est passé de 8% à
moins de 3% ce qui montre le poids
relatif des agriculteurs alors qu'il est
essentiel tout de même est moins
important peut-être que par rapport au
gilet jaune ce qui peut sans doute
expliquer cette différence de
mobilisation mais néanmoins les
problèmes sont graves aujourd'hui en
termes de revenus on a vu qu'il ya un
taux de suicide très important chez des
agriculteurs et vous avez tout à fait
raison de souligner que 50 % des
agriculteurs dans les années qui
viennent vont partir à la retraite
il ya donc urgence d'aider les jeunes
agriculteurs et choix que ces deux sens
du discours du président de la
république marcelo on parle là du du
poids des agriculteurs et c'est vrai
qu'en pourcentage
il est faible par rapport au reste de la
population n'en est pas seulement dans
la plus grande ferme de france on est
dans la plus grande ferme
politique de france c'est à dire que
c'est un rendez vous incontournable des
politiques s'est ouvert au public et
donc on va on a le contexte agricole
mais on a aussi le contexte où on a une
mobilisation des gilets jaunes qui est
en baisse mais qui étend radicalisation
qui se manifeste par des actes violents
parfois vu raciste antisémite et le
risque aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
d'avoir des interpellations venue du
monde agricole pour le président de la
république c'est d'avoir des
interpellations venue de cette frange la
plus radicale it et qui aujourd'hui
pour ce 15e samedi va essayer de
relancer la machine des gilets jaunes
qui est en train de s'essouffler vous
disais un marcelo c'est un salon très
politique peut-être plus que les années
précédentes alors il à ce mouvement dès
gilet jaune mais il ya aussi le grand
débat et est bien ce grand débat il sera
au coeur de ce salon cette année
puisqu'il y aura des grands débats ici
aussi au salon alors l'idée avec les
grands débats ça a été de retisser le
lien avec le monde rural c'est vraiment
on va dire le fil rouge de cette
initiative de la part d' emmanuel macron
qui est allé beaucoup au contact des
maires ruraux
alors là on nous a dit non le discours
portera sur l'avenir l'europe agricole
on parlera agriculture mais il est
évidemment très difficile de disjoindre
les questions rurales et les questions
agricoles
on attend alors un emmanuel macron on le
disait dans les minutes à venir il
commencera par un discours et marcelo
c'est vrai que inauguré le salon de
l'agriculture pour un président de la
république eh bien c'est une tradition
c'est une tradition c'est un grand
classique avec une petite exception un
françois mitterrand aimait pas du tout
le salon est né comme président ne venez
pas mais on sait par exemple que jacques
chirac n'en a loupé aucun apparent 79
quand il a eu un accident de voiture
on sait que hollande est venu françois
hollande et qu'il a il a fait des des
visites marathon jusqu'à 12h en 2012 et
ensuite c'est twitter
on sait que nicolas sarkozy est venu et
on se souvient qu'il avait prononcé
cette fameuse phrase le casse toi pauvre
con qui montre bien que c'est vraiment
le salon de tous les dangers c'est à
dire que vous êtes à porter
d'interpellations et vous c'est le jeu
de la spontanéité jeu dans lequel
excelle
emmanuel macron et en même temps la vue
y est avant-hier avec quand il a reçu
les présidents de départements
il est aussi de temps en temps victime
de ça son aisance et son côté un peu la
petite phrase jugée arrogante qui va
ensuite suscité le tollé
donc on verra aujourd'hui aussi quel
type de spontané l'europe il aura est ce
qu'elle est bienveillante wasquehal et
redresseuse de torts ce sera peut-être
un sujet de polémique on verra ce soir
on verra tout ça un patrick martin
geniez c'est vrai que c'est un passage
obligé mais qu'on le dit comme le disait
marcelo c'est un passage risqué mais
c'est toujours un passage risqué mais
c'est très politique il ya un grand
symbole et housse avec le symbole en
politique ça compte beaucoup
il faut que les présidents la république
les ministres de l'agriculture
successifs montrent leur soutien aux
agriculteurs qui en ont besoin et
l'objectif aujourd'hui tu présent la
république je pense qu'il sera peut-être
très attentif sur les petites phrases
mais l'objectif est bien de partir à la
reconquête de l'opinion publique
avec ce mouvement du gilet jaune qui a
fait du mal également avec il ya eu le
grand débat national est aujourd'hui eh
bien il faut pas se le cacher nous
sommes partir en campagne pour les
élections européennes
tant qu'il ya un réel objectif
stratégique pour le président de la
république aujourd'hui
alors puisque vous parliez à cette
campagne européenne c'est vrai que ce
discours d'inauguration du salon de
l'agriculture a lieu à trois mois des
européennes tam et emmanuel macron et
bien donc choisi de centrer son discours
sur l'europe agricole et oui
effectivement henrianne emmanuel macron
a évidemment cette échéance électorale
en tête il va centrer son discours sur
la politique agricole commune est
l'importance d'avoir une unité
européenne sur ces questions il faut
coopérer et pas diviser on ne peut pas
avoir une france agricole forte que si
on l'a on a une europe agricole forte
elle devrait être le sens de son message
adressé devant 1 500 personnes pour
moitié de jeunes agriculteurs européens
et puis on nous annonce un certain
nombre de personnalités à ses côtés bien
sûr et bien les ministres il y aura des
vidéos mais une ministre de
l'agriculture françois de rugy le
istres de la transition écologique mais
aussi la ministre des affaires
européennes à nathalie l'oiseau c'est à
noter ainsi que frédéric vidal la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
mais notez qu'il y aura aussi des
personnalités européennes notamment le
commissaire européen à l'agriculture
phil hogan et bien sûr et bien il y aura
aussi michel barnier le grand
négociateur du break site
alors je rappelle que cette dimension
européenne vient compléter une politique
nationale qui a été fait au niveau
agricole pour l'exécutif qui jugent
qu'il a fait qu'il faut à ce niveau avec
les états généraux de l'alimentation le
projet de loi et galim qui pour
l'exécutif commence à produire ses
premiers effets qui doit permettre de
rémunérer plus justement les
agriculteurs mais qui a aussi engendré
une augmentation des prix désormais le
reste dépendrait donc de l'europe une
europe qui est fragilisée par le break
site qui s'annonce comment maintenir le
budget de la pac sans la contribution du
royaume uni je le disais hé bien la
présence de michel barnier lors de ce
discours est bien elle compte et elle
montre combien la france veut préserver
aussi et bien une pac forte alors que
l'europe est bientôt en transformation
merci ta main et vous notez bien sûr au
courant dès que le président de la
république fait son entrée dans ce hall
1 avant de venir à cette question du
bric site un mot sur ces images en
direct devant l'entrée du salon de
l'agriculture le salon qui va ouvrir ses
portes dans un quart d'heure maintenant
première journée d'ouverture au public
et vous le voyez le public est déjà
nombreux devant cette entrée du salon de
l'agriculture
partrick matin geniez tam en parlait à
l'instant un michel barnier est présent
ce matin au côté du président de la
république parce que c'est vrai que ce
bric site
et bien c'est une inquiétude forte pour
le monde agricole
c'est une très grosse inquiétude et avec
raison car c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que
le bric si tu ne vas pas avoir des
conséquences uniquement pour les
britanniques mais également pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
donc si nous n'aboutissons pas à un
accord et aujourd'hui les dirigeants
sont réunis aujourd'hui à charm el
cheikh en egypte pour négocier sur autre
chose mais il valait par des
négociations en coulisses il faut
absolument que nous arrivions à un
accord
pourquoi parce que le royaume uni 7 9%
des exportations de l'ensemble des 27
autres pays de l'union européenne abe
et si jamais nous avons apprécié c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas d'accord il y aura
une augmentation des taxes et cela
risque de réduire de 50 à 60%
les exportations en tout cas cela va
conduire à une augmentation de taxes
d'un côté comme de l'autre d'ailleurs
et donc cela aura des conséquences très
importantes notamment sur l'agriculture
mais également sur la politique agricole
beaucoup politique commune de la pêche
car vous avez vu qu' il n'y a pas
d'accord dans l'accord politique été
négocié au mas des sens on ne dit rien
sur la politique de la pêche et par
conséquent cela risque d'aboutir à des
affrontements et cela va handicaper
considérablement les exportations des
produits agricoles et agroalimentaires
au royaume uni et il faut préciser que
la pêche les eaux britanniques sont très
importantes pour les pêcheurs français
notamment les pêcheurs du nord qui
dépend de la 50 % des eaux britanniques
voilà absolument on va essentiellement
dans les eaux britanniques et en plus
les pêcheurs britannique estime que eux
leurs productions étant très bonne ils
n'auront aucune difficulté pour exporter
qui au japon qui en chine et donc on va
rentrer dans un système manque de
concurrence très très important ou non
parmentier cette question du brics
italie crucial pour les agriculteurs et
notamment pour les pêcheurs comme le
disait patrick matin genia l'instant oui
en même temps il faut bien se rendre
compte
la grande bretagne est incapable de se
nourrir toute seule et donc on va voir
s'il va se passer dans un mois ou deux
il va y avoir des rayons vides dans les
supermarchés donc ça va ruer dans les
brancards
donc ils ont besoin de nos fruits et
légumes ils en produisent pas quasiment
donc je ne sais pas alors l'idée de dire
le commonwealth et grands va porter des
fruits et légumes d'australie je demande
à voir
et donc de fait cette désorganisation va
bien montrer que l'europe agricole
c'est quelque chose de fondamental pour
l'agriculture en fait on est un grand
pays agricole c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui mais on est tout petit notre
agriculture est 20 fois plus petit que
l'agriculture chinoise il faut se rendre
compte si on n'est pas capable de
s'associer dans le continent pour faire
de l'agriculture on est mort dans la
concurrence internationale et tout le
problème c'est comment s'organise en
europe avec des gens qui ont des
rapports très différents avec
l'alimentation
regardez chez nous par exemple pour
déjeuner dans les conventions
collectives ont dit pas moins d'une
heure pour déjeuner on s'assoit on
déjeune etc
bon hollande ce qu'on appelle déjeuner
c'est manger du pain de mie carrés avec
du jambon carré et du fromage car et on
s'en fiche qui attend du moment que
c'est pas cher on le regarde devant
l'ordinateur est donc le rapport à la
nourriture est extrêmement différents or
on ne peut pas ne pas s'entendre pour
exister sur la planète alimentaire
notamment face aux néo normes défis qui
sont devant nous le défi environnemental
le défi du réchauffement climatique etc
on a vraiment besoin d'une vraie
politique agricole commune et ça c'est
très significatif qu'il en parle et
c'est très significatif qu'il en parle
devant des jeunes européens aussi et ce
sera l'un des points forts du discours
du chef de l'état à marcelo le fait de
dire eh bien une france agricole forte
ça passe par une europe agricole forte
voilà c'est à dire développer un
discours européen pro-européen positif
est d'ailleurs sur la question du bric
site
on voit bien que depuis plusieurs
semaines le chef de l'état utilise cet
exemple pour mon comme un épouvantail
pour dire aux gens aux eurosceptiques
regardez le résultat chez nos voisins
regarder les craintes regarder les
turbulences que ça a provoqué la
solution elle est européenne et donc il
va essayer de développer un discours
positif et ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que si on compare le bilan du président
sur le plan européen sert les avancées
en termes de l'alliance franco-allemande
en terme de budget la zone euro en
termes mêmes de directive sur les
travailleurs détachés
c'est pas extraordinaire faut quand même
le dire en revanche il est une bête de
campagne on l'a vu récemment dans ses
rangs rencontre avec les élus et donc
rien et offensive avec un discours
puisque là il sera clairement campagne
avec un investissement personnel on sait
qu'il participera à des meeting pour les
européennes c'est une façon pour lui
d'endosser un discours positive et
d'essayer de de conforter cette
dynamique on commence à voir dans les
sondages puisque il apparaît
actuellement qui lui dit premier dans
les sondages pour les européennes
alors ça commence à bouger à on le voit
dans le hall où est attendu
annuel macron vous l'avez vu furtivement
sur ces images l'arrivée de didier
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation françois de rugy
également ministre de la transition
écologique emmanuel macron ne devrait
donc pas tarder à commencer son discours
patrick martin joly on en parlait à
l'instant avec marcelo avec bruno
parmentier la question de cette europe
forte
emmanuel macron devrait aussi insister
sur le fait et bien qu'il va falloir
lutter face à la concurrence chinoise
faber on en parlera tout à l'heure
patrick martin geniez puisqu'on vend en
direct sur ces images le président d'un
public vient d'arriver on écoute celui
d'état mesdames messieurs les ministres
mesdames messieurs les commissaires
européens et des messieurs les députés
sénateurs parlementaires européens
mesdames messieurs les ambassadeurs
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
syndicaux et de filières mesdames
messieurs les préfets et directeurs
mesdames et messieurs si très heureux
d'être avec vous en ce samedi matin est
à ce jour en effet d'ouverture d'autres
salons auxquels nous tenons tant pour
vous parler d'agriculture et pour vous
parler d'europe
et pour parler tout particulièrement
d'agriculture et d'europe à la jeunesse
qui veut embrasser cette vocation aussi
parce que c'est une vocation
et ce n'est pas qu'un métier aucune
activité depuis 20 mois la france à
adopter des mesures fortes pour soutenir
son agriculture
je n'ignore rien des difficultés du
quotidien des drames qui se jouent
encore de tous que depuis trop d'années
nous connaissons dans certaines de nos
régions certaines de nos filières
néanmoins se constate avec vous que
parce qu'il ya une mobilisation
collective dans plusieurs secteurs dans
plusieurs régions les choses sont en
train de s'améliorer avec les états
généraux de l'alimentation puis la loi
alimentation avec le relèvement du seuil
de revente à perte
l'encadrement des promotions le recours
possibles en cas de prix abusivement bas
le gouvernement a pris à bras
justement l'enjeu de la répartition de
la valeur entre ceux qui produisent ce
qui transforme et ceux qui distribuent
les produits agricoles
c'était attendu soutenu depuis de
nombreuses années en particulier par
l'ensemble des syndicats agricoles je
dois le dire et ça a été fait
les plans de filières ont également
permis d'obtenir des avancées majeures
objectifs en matière de montée en gamme
contractualisation et peu à peu
s'organise un système où la valeur doit
revenir et reviendra pour une juste part
à celles et ceux qui produisent et nous
avons fait sur ce sujet un pari le
gouvernement avec le parlement
celui de responsabiliser les filières et
ce pari commence à porter ses fruits
l'un des secteurs comme la volaille
l'oeuf la pomme de terre la transparence
est aujourd'hui faite sur les
indicateurs de coûts de production les
résultats s'améliorent parce que des
contractualisations se sont aussi
multipliés permettant de peser davantage
dans la négociation je pense par exemple
au lait et nous obtenons ainsi de bons
résultats dans les négociations en cours
je veux remercier chacun des acteurs
d'avoir pris leur part parce que par
exemple pour les éleveurs laitiers c'est
l'opportunité de mieux vivre de leur
travail et de retrouver des perspectives
de ces combats ne lâcheront rien
toutes les filières tous les acteurs
doivent continuer à se mobiliser et j'y
veillerai avec le ministre
personnellement ça ne se fera pas en un
jour
nous le savons bien et je sais
l'impatience qu'il y aille je sais que
certains se disent est ce que l'argent
est revenu dans la cour de la ferme pas
encore totalement les négociations
commerciales sont en cours qui
permettront d'obtenir ce résultat mais
nous devons avoir cette vigilance et
vous avez raison mais ça suppose une
responsabilité et une responsabilisation
de chacun parce que nous n'avons pas
décidé de nous attaquer simplement aux
symptômes ou de les réparer ou de
corriger avec de l'argent public
des séries dysfonctionnements nous avons
décidé de nous attaquer aux causes
profondes et donc il faut
progressivement changer les habitudes
des pelé qui avait été mal formés et
revenir sur beaucoup de cela mais
aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau combat que
je souhaite avec vous engager devant
vous jeunes agriculteurs venus de tout
le continent
je suis venu évoquer une politique sans
laquelle nos actions nationales serait
inefficace une politique sans laquelle
l'agriculture française ne serait pas ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
je suis venu vous parler de la politique
agricole européenne
je crois dans la force du modèle
français et je suis comme vous un
patriote de notre agriculture
je crois dans la force de nos terroirs
et l'attachement que beaucoup d'entre
vous ont alors région la force de leur
territoire les aoc les aop ou tout ce
qui fait notre fierté
mais je sais aussi que cette force de
nos terroirs de notre pays ne serait pas
la même sans notre europe et je sais que
l'avenir de ce terroir français de ses
terroirs français passe par une
politique agricole européenne
protectrice pragmatique ambitieuse dont
nous avons besoin pour cela il y a
si je puis dire une exigence première
exigence d'unité
il s'agit pour moi d'un enjeu crucial
l'europe agricole qui reste à ce jour la
première puissance mondiale l'europe
agricole qui assure à tous les peuples
une alimentation saine et sur l'europe
agricole qui porte haut cette
civilisation du bien manger de la
gastronomie de l'art de vivre l'europe
agricole qui pour vous pour moi a
toujours été une évidence l'europe
agricole est aujourd'hui menacé
elle l'est depuis l'extérieur par des
grandes puissances qui n'hésitent plus à
adopter des stratégies offensives pour
imposer leurs normes et leurs standards
par un ordre international qui à force
de considérer la nourriture comme une
marchandise parmi d'autres a fini par
perdre son âme menacer l'europe agricole
est aussi de l'intérieur par ceux qui au
prétexte que la pâte serait imparfaite
ou quelle n'est pas leur priorité
voudrait la re nationaliser qui au
prétexte qu'elle ne répondrait pas à
tous les espoirs placés en elle voudrait
une pac réduite aux acquêts
si je tenais à m'exprimer à l'occasion
de ce salon
quelques semaines avant les élections
européennes et alors que la nouvelle pac
est en cours de discussion à bruxelles
c'est donc pour exhorter à l'unité et à
la mobilisation et je veux ici tout
particulièrement salué la présence du
commissaire vaughan merci commissaire
pour votre engagement en la matière et
la présence du ministre commissaire
barnier qui ne se bat ça pas simplement
pour l'unité de l'europe dans le
contexte du bric site
mais pour la force de notre europe plus
largement dans un monde qui parfois se
disloque
merci à vous d'être présents ce matin et
je le sais de partager cette exigence
d'unité en maintenant ensemble ce combat
je suis venu vous dire et à travers vous
aux agriculteurs aux dirigeants aux
peuples européens que l'europe agricole
est un bien précieux qu'il nous faut
protéger
à tout prix car ne nous trompons pas le
vrai risque qui guette notre agriculture
ce n'est pas comme on l'entend parfois
la concurrence entre états européens
ce n'est pas pour l'agriculture
française la concurrence des fruits
espagnols pour les arboriculteurs du
port allemand ou de la volaille
polonaise pour les éleveurs c'est un
défi de chaque jour je fais l'impatience
que cela crée parfois les distorsions
qu'il faut corriger
non le vrai risque n'est pas là le vrai
risque qui guette agriculture européenne
c'est ce serait notre dépendance aux
importations d'engrais phosphatés russe
c'est le fait que 70% du bétail européen
soit nourrie par du soja ogm importés et
donc que le prix de nos yeux de nos
volailles soit tributaire de
l'augmentation du coût de ses matières
premières qui ne manqueront pas sous
l'effet de l'augmentation de la demande
chinoise de ce progressivement se faire
c'est ça
c'est progressivement notre dépendance à
l'égard d'intrants venant d'autres
continents d'autres puissances notre
dépendance pour notre propre production
et notre souveraineté alimentaire à
l'égard d'autres continents d'autres
puissances qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec la pac ou une concurrence au sein
de l'europe mais dont les intérêts
profonds peuvent être et seront
immanquablement à la fin divergent alors
on peut bien sûr critiquer certains
aspects de la stratégie européenne mais
je suis sûr d'une chose c'est que sans
la pac
cette politique commune voulue par les
pères fondateurs
les consommateurs européens ne
bénéficieraient pas aujourd'hui d'une
alimentation accessible et de qualité
je suis sûr aussi que sans la pac
l'europe ne sera pas en capacité de
faire valoir ses choix au monde et donc
oui notre défi ça n'est pas simplement
comme le voudraient certains de liquider
l'héritage de plus de 60 ans de
politique agricole commune de céder au
poison lent de la division et c'est bien
de réinventer cette politique agricole
commune
aujourd'hui et c'est pour moi une
question de souveraineté de souveraineté
alimentaire environnementale industriels
c'est à dire de pouvoir faire en tant
que citoyen européen
nos choix et que la jeunesse européenne
puisse les faire si nous cédons à
l'esprit de division alors dans cinq ans
dans dix ans dans 15 ans nous ne
pourront plus garantir à nos concitoyens
une alimentation saine en tout cas
totalement traçable et indépendante en
europe nous ne pourront plus garantir la
cohérence d'une politique
environnementale nous imposeront à nos
producteurs des normes de poussan tout
dur mais juste trop dépendants en
d'intrants ou d'un port de puissance qui
ne respecteront pas les mêmes règles et
nous laisseront ainsi s'effriter des
filières de l'emploi des territoires qui
dépendent de la force de cette politique
commune
aucun agriculteur aucun consommateur ne
souhaite demain être soumis aux normes
au standard au prix et finalement au
diktat des non européens
c'est pour cela par exemple que nous
voulons porter un plan protéines
ambitieux à l'échelle du continent
c'est revenir sur des décennies on le
sait de déséquilibre de dépendance c'est
sur une histoire en particulier avec le
continent américain il ça a été
commencée au niveau européen il ya
plusieurs années nous devons l'accélérer
et c'est indispensable en france et en
europe pour pouvoir être pleinement
dépendant indépendant pardon et pour
pouvoir construire la cohérence de nos
filières c'est une question aussi de
valeurs nous cultivons en europe une
certaine idée du rapport entre l'homme
et la nature
fondée sur eux le bien manger l'art de
vivre le respect de la faune et de la
flore et je crois que personne ici ne
veut y renoncer et défendre ces valeurs
c'est vouloir que celles ci qui sont
portés de manière inédite en europe
puissent prospérer et vous le voyez tous
ces enjeux que je suis venu partager
aujourd'hui avec vous vous qu'il y
aurait à les mettre en oeuvre a décidé
des choix à prendre dans les mois à
venir pour les dirigeants européens
et vous qui aurait la tâche de
réconcilier l'agriculture et la société
dans toutes ses composantes
ce que je crois est ce que défendra la
france c'est que la prochaine politique
agricole européenne a d'abord besoin de
cette unité est ensuite c'est que cette
politique agricole européenne doit tenir
trois promesses pour sa jeunesse
agricole
une promesse de protection des
agriculteurs et des consommateurs
une promesse de transformation de notre
modèle vers toujours plus de valeur et
plus d'écologie une promesse enfin
d'anticipation en misant sur la
recherche et en assurant le
renouvellement des générations et ce
sont sur ces trois promesses quelques
mots que je veux vous dire promesse de
protection d'abord l'agriculture est un
secteur fait d'engager qui consacrent
leur vie à garantir l'un des droits les
plus fondamentaux de l'homme se nourrir
et cet engagement oblige
et c'est pour ça que je disais il ya un
instant que notre alimentation que la
nourriture ne sera jamais une
marchandise comme les autres
cet engagement oblige la société un
devoir de protection vis-à-vis de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui nous nourrissent
et ce devoir de protection
ceux qui ont imaginé puis appliquer la
politique agricole commune ne l'ont
jamais perdu de vue
quelle que soit la forme des dispositifs
déployés quotas aide directe la pac a
toujours cherché à protéger les
agriculteurs pour cette raison même
c'est une histoire qu'il nous faut
poursuivre et si la france défend ce
moment à bruxelles un budget ambitieux
pour la pac
un budget qui doit à traduire les
conséquences du bric site mais pas plus
et pas pour un euro de plus si la france
défend ce budget à bruxelles c'est avant
tout pour cela pour que ce devoir de
protection que nous avons vis-à-vis de
celles et ceux qui nous nourrissent soit
honorée aujourd'hui comme hier et qu'on
avait pas me dire que ce budget qui
consiste à protéger viendrait protéger
contre le changement ou du changement il
faut ne pas avoir regardé l'agriculture
européenne et au premier chef
agriculture française pour voir les
changements qui ont été été effectués
qu'on me dise qu'on vient de prendre
profession ont été ainsi bousculé par
les changements depuis tant de décennies
non c'est précisément que ce ne sont pas
les professions comme les autres c'est
précisément que ce ne sont pas des
engagés comme les autres et ceux qui ne
veulent pas voir cela nous font courir
un risque fondamental c'est de voir
disparaître des filières entières et
donc de construire notre dépendance
là encore à l'égard de l'extérieur
doit-on pour autant tout figé
doit-on renoncer à simplifier notre
système je ne crois pas on peut protéger
réaffirmé cette ambition et vouloir et
pouvoir faire mieux
en france c'est notre pays doit bien le
dire en est responsable
nous avons un système qui est trop
complexe à cet égard 9500 mesures
agro-environnementales mon courage
doit-on ignorait les distorsions
fiscales ou sociétales sociales qui
existent entre les différents pays
bien sûr que non en même temps que nous
garantissons les moyens financiers
alloués à la pac nous devons sinon la
refonder au moins la faire évoluer très
fortement
l'enjeu principal c'est de mieux prendre
en compte les aléas comme les
catastrophes climatiques les chutes
soudaines de prix c'est de mettre en
place au niveau européen une gestion
performante du risque la vraie
protection et la fel ci est en effet
aujourd'hui imparfaite et j'ai dialogué
avec nombre d'entre vous qui ont encore
récemment vécu pour les uns une
sécheresse très dur où une sécheresse à
nouveau si j'oserais si j'ose le dire
ainsi très dur des inondations pour
d'autres et je vous ai vue pour certains
la boule au ventre en guettant
l'évolution de cours boursiers qui ne
dépendent pas de vous mais d'un marché
aveugle adossé à la volatilité des prix
qu'il s'agisse du pétrole ou d'autres
matières premières fait ça aujourd'hui
la réalité de nos agriculteurs
c'est l' angoisse à l'égard de ta
d'aller à face auxquels on ne peut rien
on ne peut rien face à l'aléa climatique
et on ne peut rien quand on est un
agriculteur et qu'on a déjà
pas de jour de congé face aux cours
mondiaux dont on est dépendant pour
produire et vendre et donc face à tout
cela et pour y remédier et je prends ici
l'engagement que soit inscrit dans la
nouvelle pac
l'objectif de protéger les agriculteurs
d'europe des risques climatiques de
marché inhérents à votre métiers
protégés
cela ne veut pas dire comme on l'a
parfois fruits dans les crises récentes
je pense là aussi à la crise des tiers
de 2015 2016
ça veut pas dire octroyé d'abord des
aides à la production puis donner des
aides pour réduire la production avant
finalement de stocker de la poudre de
lait dans une sortie de confusion
absurde en essayant docile et de
s'adapter et chaque fois aux coups de
boutoir justement de ces évolutions non
c'est développer une véritable stratégie
de gestion des risques
c'est cela ce que nous devons faire
maintenant pour véritablement protégée
ça passe d'abord par une réserve de
crise européenne pluriannuel réactive
pour protéger l'ensemble des états
membres de l'impact des crises de marché
ensuite par des mécanismes de régulation
des filières plus performant plus
facilement activable que ceux existant
avec en particulier une meilleure
articulation entre dispositifs privé
responsabilisant les entreprises et les
outils publics de gestion des risques
troisièmement une diversification des
cultures des bassins de production et un
accompagnement au changement des
pratiques pour mieux s'adapter aux
changements climatiques
c'est une évolution indispensable et
c'est une politique de prévention
d'accompagnement est essentielle
le tout en conservant les aides à
l'hectare qui constitue un filet de
sécurité pour les agriculteurs en
complément des dispositifs existants au
niveau des états comme les pains de
protection que nous venons de mettre en
place en france lors des dernières lois
de finances
si l'europe doit protéger les
agriculteurs
elle doit aussi et c'est d'ailleurs une
des vocations historique de l'union
tenir sa promesse de protection des
consommateurs
c'est la protection jumelles que
demandent de plus en plus les citoyens
européens en matière d'alimentation tout
simplement de savoir ce qu'il mange de
savoir où et comment ce qu'ils mangent a
été produit transformé et cette demande
c'est à nouveau à l'échelle de l'europe
que nous pouvons y répondre nous le
faisons quand nous refusons dans le
cadre des négociations commerciales que
les produits importés déroge à nos
normes et je tiens ici à le redire c'est
là aussi notre cohérence et la ford
celle ci si on veut protéger nos
agriculteurs et nos consommateurs
nous devons avoir une politique
commerciale européenne cohérente et je
leur dis avec force
aucun accord commercial ne saurait
autoriser des produits ne respectant pas
les standards européens standards
environnementaux sanitaires et sociaux
c'est notre ligne rouge
quinon s'est demandé aux producteurs
européens de faire des efforts des
évolutions et le jour d'après ouvrir des
accords commerciaux avec des pays qui ne
respectent aucun des standards que nous
sommes en train de définir ce serait
absurde est en quelque sorte ce serait
réduire la compétitivité des producteurs
sans garantir la qualité pour les
consommateurs c'est pour cela que la
france s'est opposée avec la commission
européenne à toutes négociations
commerciales sur les produits agricoles
avec les états-unis l'union doit aussi
se donner les moyens de traquer les
fraudes
de poursuivre celles et ceux qui jouent
avec la santé des consommateurs tout en
installant des situations de concurrence
déloyale
c'est pourquoi la france qui est
exemplaire en la matière comme nous
l'avons encore vu récemment avec la
problématique les viandes oeufs frelaté
venant de pologne la france porte la
création d'une force européenne pour
lutter contre les fraudes et garantir la
sécurité alimentaire
nous maintenons notre volonté que
l'étiquetage de l'origine des viandes
soit indiquée dans les produits
transformés
ce qui est indispensable pour
accompagner ce mouvement
mais cette force européenne c'est la
garantie d'une politique ambitieuse
homogène au niveau européen en matière
d'exigences sanitaires et de contrôle
c'est la garantie qu'on apporte qu'il
n'y ait pas une forme de dumping sur la
qualité de notre avenir notre
alimentation qui est en quelque sorte
des points d'entrée ou de faiblesse au
sein de l'europe on accepterait moins de
contrôles moins de qualité et donc la
circulation d'une alimentation moins
exigeante pour nos consommateurs face à
ce sujet crucial
il nous faut être plus exigeant encore
dans de nombreux secteurs se développe
actuellement la technologie de la blocs
chaîne qui permet de garantir la
provenance et la traçabilité d'un
produit faisons à cet égard de leur pop
l'avant-garde de la data agricole en
développant des outils qui permettront
de suivre chaque produit depuis la
production de la matière première
jusqu'à l'emballage en passant par la
transformation et le transport
l'innovation est là et elle est là dans
le monde agricole
il faut l'utiliser à plein car elle est
au service de l'excellence partager et
elle sera elle aussi au service du
consommateur
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons faire
preuve de plus de transparence pour
renouer une vraie relation de confiance
entre nos concitoyens
la deuxième promesse c'est la promesse
de transformation vers la qualité et
l'écologie qui réconcilie là encore
l'aspiration des agriculteurs la
préférence collective des consommateurs
avec le soutien aux agriculteurs
l'ap a créé par un peu des imperfections
du présent et des erreurs du passé
elle doit aussi veiller à préparer
l'avenir en incitant les agriculteurs à
investir et à innover à accélérer la
transition et de ce point de vue le
combat prioritaire et celui de la valeur
le défi l'agriculture européenne pour
demain ce n'est pas de faire moins sûr
que les poulets brésilien le les néo
zélandais ou la viande produite par les
fields brésiliens n'ont ni la géographie
ni notre modèle social ni notre ambition
environnementale ne nous le permettent
le défi de notre agriculture de
l'agriculture européenne
c'est de se différencier c'est de
s'appuyer sur des savoir-faire
pluriséculaire sur l'image de qualité
que des décennies d'excellence ont
précisément permis d'acquérir le défi de
notre agriculture est bien là et cette
quête de la qualité et de l'écologie
passe en premier lieu par la
structuration des filières
nous avons commencé à agir au niveau
français et je rencontrerai encore tout
à l'heure les différentes filières mais
le bon niveau c'est le niveau européen
c'est en effet à cette échelle là qu'il
est possible de pratiquer à plein la
segmentation c'est-à-dire de
sélectionner pour chaque territoire en
fonction de son contexte climatique
géologique sociales culturelles des
productions les plus adaptées celles qui
présentent l'avantagé comparatif le plus
important
c'est à cette échelle là aussi que nous
pouvons bâtir des stratégies intégrées
en matière de logistique de stockage de
transformation je pense à la filière blé
aujourd'hui le blé français est
concurrencé sur le marché mondial par le
pdt les russes ou ukrainiens produits
dans des fermes de milliers d'hectares
dix fois plus grande que les plus
grandes de nos fermes et sur ce secteur
en quelques années le monde s'est
transformé
j'évoque le blé russe il y a cinq ans
nous parlons là d'un de nos principaux
clients
il est devenu l'un de nos plus
redoutables compétiteurs le monde se
transforme à une vitesse folle mais en
seulement quelques années la production
de blé russe a doublé le blé ukrainien
est devenu un acteur de référence et le
blé est un actif stratégique il nous
faut bien sûr conservés mais nous n'y
parviendrons pas en nous positionnant
uniquement sur le segment de la
compétitivité coûts et sur les flux
poussé parce qu'il sera on le sait bien
certaine année difficile de rivaliser
même sur nos marchés historiques
nous devons viser une plus forte
segmentation certes en gardant notre
capacité de production mais en misant
aussi sur des blés à forte teneur
protéique sur nos savoir faire en
matière de planification et en
développant une offre complète beaucoup
plus différenciée
c'est en déployant une offre technique
complète adaptée aux besoins de nos
clients en louant sur notre marché
domestique sur les marchés européens
une offre différenciée en ont en eux
aussi une nouvelle relation avec
l'afrique que nous rivaliseront et que
nous éviterons en quelque sorte la
compétition mortifère vers le prix le
plus bas
votre génération on ne peut pas lui dire
qu'elle va embrasser l'avenir en allant
faire la compétition contre d'autres
agriculteurs qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes n'auront jamais les mêmes
contraintes et vous pousseront
le prix le plus bas si nous allons dans
cette direction nous vous condamnons
soit au christ démocratiques les plus
profondes soit l'échec climatique qui
serait fatal pour chacun soit au malheur
et donc je crois très profondément que
nous devons construire cette stratégie
de segmentation de différenciation qui
en même temps correspond à notre adn
profond et à l'ambition qui a toujours
été la nôtre
j'évoquais à l'instant en parlant des
céréales l'afrique et je veux en dire un
mot tout particulièrement
chacun connaît ici les perspectives
démographiques du continent africain il
va voir sa population doubler d'ici 2050
et cet enjeu qui est un défi pour le
continent africain qui est un défi pour
l'europe parce que nos destins sont liés
c'est aussi un défi pour notre
agriculture
c'est une opportunité si nous savons la
saisir
chacun sait les effets qu'exerce le
réchauffement climatique sur la
pérennité de la ressource en eau la
fertilité des sols avec un désert qui ne
cessent de gagner du terrain et face à
toutes ces perspectives l'afrique
parmi ses principaux défis un défi
agricole et alimentaire l'agriculture
sera un pilier non seulement du maintien
de l'afrique mais de sa réussite de la
capacité à offrir un avenir à la
jeunesse africaine de se développer de
se nourrir a le même lors de chacun de
mes déplacements sur ce continent
j'ai perçu cette attente et avec
l'éducation et la santé c'est le
troisième pilier pour moi de la
stratégie de développement partagé avec
l'afrique que nous devons conduire et
qu'elle met ses savoir-faire son
expertise au service d'une démarche de
long terme pour développer des filières
agricoles pérenne et rentable
en afrique c'est le rôle de la france et
de l'europe
nos partenaires en afrique ne veulent
plus des recettes du passé non plus ils
ne veulent plus d'une vision
misérabiliste de l'afrique d'une vision
cantonné à la petite exploitation
vivrières ils veulent construire une
afrique forte forte de filières
agricoles créatrice d'emplois deux
valeurs et qui permettront in fine et de
donner un avenir aux populations locales
et précisément sur ce sujet aussi nous
la france l'europe
nous devons être au rendez-vous de cette
attente et je le dis pour l'ensemble des
agriculteurs européens ici présents
comme des décideurs
c'est une opportunité pour nous à saisir
opportunités de développement partagé
opportuniste et d'exportation de nos
savoir-faire et opportunités pour nous
aider à faire réussir le continent
africain
vous l'aurez compris nous devons donc
définir des stratégies européennes
filière par filière et pour ça il faut
s'organiser en amont dans les choix de
production
il faut agir en aval en investissant
dans le maillon industriels pour que la
transformation de nos produits et donc
la captation de valeur ne se fasse pas à
l'extérieur du continent mais bien en
europe sur nos territoires et sur ce
sujet cet en particulier tout le sens du
grand plan d'investissement que nous
portons au niveau national et je
remercie olivier allain pour son
investissement au côté du ministre dans
cette entreprise
et c'est aussi l'ambition du fonds
d'investissement européen doté d'un
milliard d'euros qui vient d'être lancé
et je tiens à saluer la présence parmi
nous de monsieur fayolle le
vice-président de la banque européenne
d'investissement profondément engagés
dans cette ambition faire bloc
plutôt que de nous perdre dans une
concurrence qui nous affaiblit
collectivement coopérer plutôt que de
nous diviser nous comporter en
partenaire et non en concurrents c'est
la ligne que nous ne devons jamais
cesser de suivre
le combat pour la valeur passe ensuite
par un virage assumé vers ce qui est le
combat de votre génération et qui répond
à une demande forte de plus en plus
pressante de nos consommateurs de nos
citoyens et tout particulièrement de
notre jeunesse la protection de
l'environnement
nous avons vu hier la jeunesse
européenne qui s'est mobilisé avec
beaucoup de force et de sincérité nous
n'avons reçu avec le ministre d'état
contre le réchauffement climatique
et c'est la même jeunesse que je vois
devant moi qui se mobilisent pour
nourrir l'europe c'est la même jeunesse
il n'y en a pas deux et donc c'est cette
réconciliation de deux combats
essentiels que nous devons réussir ma
conviction profonde sur ce sujet c'est
que les agriculteurs sont plus que
personne attachée à la protection de la
planète à la préservation de la
biodiversité parce qu'ils envient fait
parce qu'ils y vivent
je sais l'indignation la souffrance que
beaucoup ressentent face à ce qu'on
appelle désormais la grille bashing mais
je veux le dire sur ce sujet à tous et
toutes
moi je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un de plus
sensibles à la maltraitance animale
qu'un éleveur parce qu'il vit avec ses
bêtes parce que celui qui se réveille la
nuit quand il ya un village celui qui se
lève avec l'anxiété
quand la maladie arrive c'est l'éleveur
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi
ambitieux pour le changement climatique
le réchauffement cas d'agriculteurs
parce que celui qui envient les
conséquences chaque semaine chaque mois
qui tremblent devant la sécheresse qui
vit les conséquences de l'inondation
c'est l'agriculteur il n'y aurait pas
d'un côté des consciences du monde qui
ne vivrait pas au milieu lui et de
l'autre ceux qui seraient les pieds dans
la glaise et qui serait contre le
changement mais dans quel monde je veux
ton vie
c'est faux simplement nous avons un
monde à faire avec les contraintes du
quotidien et donc nous sommes engagés
dans une transition profonde où il faut
dans le respect de chacun
que les uns et les autres puissent vivre
dignement en conduisant ces changements
pour notre environnement
c'est ça ce que nous voulons faire et ce
que nous avons à construire au niveau
européen et donc ce lien charnel que les
agriculteurs européens ont avec la
biodiversité avec la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
il est existentiel il est dans l'adn de
notre agriculture est ma conviction
profonde c'est que les agriculteurs en
particulier les jeunes que vous êtes
doivent devenir les premiers militants
de la transition écologique
encore faut-il là aussi que les pouvoirs
publics créer les conditions de cette
transition
nous avons commencé à agir en france il
faut porter cette transition au niveau
européen la france est depuis longtemps
très en pointe sur le développement de
la certification environnementale de la
bio des mesures agro environnementales
et ceci n'a pas commencé il ya 20 mois
je le dis avec beaucoup d'humilité
c'est une conscience qui a été porté par
les agriculteurs par les militants
environnementaux qui ont aussi poussé
les pouvoirs publics depuis des années
et par nos prédécesseurs nous pouvons et
nous voulons aller encore plus loin
aujourd'hui en proposant qu'une part
significative de la prochaine pac soit
consacré à l'environnement et parce que
préserver la planète n'est pas une
option
ce budget devra concerner à part
équivalente est de manière obligatoire
l'ensemble des états membres notre
politique agricole doit également
favoriser la diversification des
activités
oui il faut encourager la production
d'énergie renouvelable
oui
il faut favoriser les initiatives visant
à accroître la capacité de stockage
carbone dans les sols et c'est le sens
du projet 4 pour mille initiée par la
france
oui il faut que la pac consacre
davantage de moyens à rémunérer les
services environnementaux rendus par les
agriculteurs pour lutter contre
l'érosion des sols préserver les
paysages entretenir les forêts stocker
le carbone préserver la qualité de l'eau
protéger les abeilles cette faune cette
flore qui fait la richesse de notre
continent
la france défendra toujours cette
fonction sociale des agriculteurs qui
par leur travail
ce culte les terroirs et les paysages et
qui fait que les agriculteurs ne sont
pas simplement des acteurs économiques
mais des acteurs essentiels de notre
ruralité au quotidien c'est à dire aussi
d'une manière de vivre déquilibre de
territoire d'une manière de préserver la
diversité de nos paysages de notre de
nos territoires et des modes de vie qui
y sont attachés c'est à dire aussi de
notre diversité profondes est
essentielle et parce que là aussi c'est
dans l'intérêt de la planète et donc de
tous c'est l'identité même de l'europe
que de concilier l'économie et
l'écologie dans un projet progressiste
pragmatique et réaliste et donc c'est
cette ambition que nous défendrons au
niveau de la pac et qui correspond à
l'ambition française que nous portons la
troisième promesses enfin c'est celle
d'anticipation cela ne vous a pas
échappé
le grand débat national a remis sur la
table beaucoup de sujets que notre pays
a vécu ces derniers mois ou ces
dernières années qui tous en notre
capacité collective à anticiper pour
n'en citer qu'un la sortie du glyphosate
j'ai rappelé récemment c'était je crois
en drôme monsieur le ministre
ma volonté sortir du glyphosate le plus
rapidement possible sous trois ans et il
ne faut pas voir cet objectif comme une
contrainte
et il ne faut pas tomber à l'égard de
cet objectif sous de faux débat c'est au
contraire une opportunité
l'opportunité pour de nombreuses
filières d'évoluer profondément
rappelez-nous d'abord d'où nous venions
nous partions en fin d'année 2010 est
vers 10 ans de renouvellement
d'autorisation du glyphosate même quinze
ans au départ la france s'est mobilisée
nous nous sommes battus pour faire voter
au niveau européen cinq années et ce que
nous voulons faire nous c'est faire
mieux pas en sueur transposant c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris donc pas en
passant dans la loi une contrainte qui
aurait créé une différence par rapport à
nos voisins mais en montrant dans les
faits que nous pouvons le faire en trois
ans par la mobilisation collective par
des solutions co-construite filière par
filière
je pense très profondément que nous
pouvons y arriver
je pense d'ailleurs très profondément
que nous sommes en train d' enclencher
la dynamique qui nous permettra d'y
arriver
je veux y voir une opportunité par
exemple quand je regarde le vignoble
français
je pense que nous pouvons en faire le
premier vignoble du monde sans
glyphosate dans 80% des cas cette
transition va d'ailleurs s'effectuer
sous trois ans elle s'effectuera parce
qu'il ya des efforts de l'innovation de
la volonté de se mobiliser
l'inra à identifier des solutions
techniques crédible et l'enjeu réside
dans la mobilisation et l'accompagnement
des filières concernées et à 15 % des
cas où les solutions techniques ne sont
pas immédiates et où nous devons nous
donner le temps de trouver des
alternatives
mais cette mobilisation permet déjà un
changement mais avec des principes
simples et là aussi l'ambition doit être
pour nous conduire à être pragmatique on
ne laissera aucun agriculteur sans
solution parce que sinon c'est une
impasse et on perd tout
et on s'assurera que toutes les
alternatives sont évalués et crédible
elles n'ont pas fait ressortir un
agriculteur de glyphosate pour l'emmener
vers un élément de substitution qui
seraient moins bons ou dont les
conséquences peut-être non évalués
serait négative là aussi il faut que
l'ambition ne s'accompagne pas de la
précipitation là l'esprit de
contradiction si nous avons ce
pragmatisme nous y arriverons et ce sera
bon pour chacun mais cet exemple nous
montre une chose c'est que nous avons
manqué d'anticipation sur ce sujet le
glyphosate pour moi et les polémiques il
ya pu avoir sur ce sujet cela dit
quelque chose d'un symptôme collectif le
symptôme de notre incapacité à nous
appuyer sur la force de nos chercheurs
de nos scientifiques pour prévoir et
anticiper on n'a pas découvert il ya 20
mois que le glyphosate était un problème
on a trop longtemps refusé de le voir et
je me souviens qui fait référence aux
heures de débats que je partage dans le
cadre de ce grand débat national en
normandie
j'ai été à juste titre sollicité par le
maire de créances sur le cas bien connu
de la carotte c'est un vrai sujet mais
parce que pendant des années on a refusé
de le voir on savait très bien on avait
donné des délais est en quelque sorte on
a dit ils ne seront pas aller on peut
essayer d'attendre encore un peu et un
moment donné on met les gens en une
situation d'impasse ministre va
s'attacher à trouver les bonnes
solutions
mais je le dis parce que la capacité que
nous devons construire à mieux connaître
mieux savoir mieux anticipé est
absolument fondamental pour toutes nos
filières et en particulier pour les
fruits et légumes auquel nous tenons
tant au fond pourquoi sur ce sujet en
sommes nous arrivés là
dans cette forme d'impasse ou de
contradiction
il ya deux raisons principales la
première c'est que nous n'avons pas pu
nous appuyer suffisamment tôt sur des
études scientifiques indépendantes et
incontesté sur les risques de cet
herbicide sur la santé humaine et pour
l'environnement et que nous avons
continué d'ailleurs ces derniers mois
avoir des débats sur ces risques
quand dans des rapports faisant autorité
on voit des passages entiers de
scientifiques ayant travaillé pour des
industriels qui sont reproduits c'est un
problème de crédibilité collectif qui
crée le doute chez nos concitoyens et
donc ça a favorisé le soupçon le
complotisme parfois l'inertie aussi chez
d'autres
pour combler cette lacune nous avons
besoin de nous doter au niveau français
et plus encore au niveau européen d'une
véritable intégrité scientifique
irréprochable c'est pourquoi la france
porte une réforme de l'autorité
européenne de la sécurité sécurité des
aliments
cette instance doit étendre son champ
d'action et se mettre en capacité
justement d'analyser les dangers et les
risques d'utilisation ou non de telle ou
telle substance chimique
elle doit devenir entièrement le tiers
de confiance qui réconcilie les
agriculteurs européens et la société et
nous devons dans le cadre de cette
réforme
apporter toutes les garanties
d'indépendance et de transparence à nos
concitoyens de tous les scientifiques
qui contribuent écrivent ou s'exprime
dans cette enceinte
c'est un élément essentiel d'abord parce
que nous avons la science européenne qui
permet de le faire et c'est ce que nous
devons à nos scientifiques
c'est un élément essentiel du débat
démocratique et de la confiance à
restaurer la seconde raison de la forme
d'impasse dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons c'est notre échec a accompagné
les changements de pratiques alors même
qu'il existait des doutes et émerger
dans l'opinion publique une demande pour
sortir du glyphosate
là encore il nous faut tirer les leçons
de cela pour l'avenir est anticipée en
france je souhaite que l'inra première
instituts agronomiques européen et
deuxième dans le monde investissent
davantage le champ économique
en travaillant avec les instituts
techniques des filières les chambres
d'agriculture
et nous faut aussi porter une recherche
agricole européenne
sur ce point la france milite pour que
le prochain budget recherche et
innovation qui sera adoptée par la
commission
alou plus de moyens à l'agriculture et à
l'alimentation ainsi pourrons-nous
multiplier des programmes tels que le
projet de recherche sur les alternatives
aux pesticides qui réunit actuellement
l'inra et deux instituts allemands dont
je salue d'ailleurs la présence dans
cette salle des représentants nous
venons par exemple de limiter pour sept
ans la dose de cuivre autorisés en
agriculture biologique en raison des
impacts sur les sols nous savons donc
qu'il nous faudra trouver une solution
quel plus bel objectif pour la recherche
européenne que de trouver une
alternative
c'est exactement sur ce type de projets
concrets que nous devons bâtir nos
partenariats réussir à refocaliser notre
recherche européennes nationales et dans
le cadre de coopération entre pays
européens pour bâtir de manière pratique
lorsqu'on sait que quelque chose est
mauvais ou qu'il ya un doute les
alternatives dans la durée tenir la
promesse d'anticipation c'est encore
agir et vous êtes les premiers concernés
pour susciter de nouvelles vocations
je parle d'anticiper anticiper les
crises anticiper les changements par la
science les transitions mais anticiper
c'est aussi anticiper le la
transformation démographique devant
laquelle nous sommes et qui va toucher
notre agriculture et notre capacité à
produire un agriculteur européen sur
deux a aujourd'hui plus de 55 ans et
partira donc à la retraite d'ici 2022
vous m'avez bien entendu un agriculteur
européen sur deux il y a donc une
urgence pour renouveler les générations
qui est absolument indispensable
une société qui ne valorise pas le
travail de la terre qu'ils ne veuillent
pas sur celles et ceux qui cultivent qui
élève
c'est une société en danger de mort est
une société qui construit les
conditions pour ne pas pouvoir se
nourrir elle même dans un monde de plus
en plus incertain et donc anticipé
puisque c'est le troisième principe
d'action que je vous propose au niveau
européen c'est anticiper le
renouvellement des générations et la
bataille indispensable que nous devons
mener pour ce faire on sait ce qui
bloque aujourd'hui c'est l'accès à la
terre agricole en raison de deux
phénomènes le premier
l'artificialisation des terres la france
pour ne parler que d'elles a perdu un
quart de sa surface agricole sur les 50
dernières années
pour y remédier nous avons fait ce choix
radical avec le gouvernement de viser le
zéro artificialisation net et donc nous
sommes en train de voir comment tenir
cet engagement en particulier dans nos
politiques d'urbanisme
c'est un véritable défi parce qu'il
vient à rebours de tout ce que nous
avons fait depuis des décennies ou si
nous regardons l'évolution de nos villes
ou plus exactement des périphéries nos
villes nos villages
nous n'avons cessé de grignoter les
terres agricoles pour ouvrir des zones
commerciales des zones industrielles des
zones de logistique
il faut rompre avec cette pratique est
là aussi le combat agricole est
pleinement réconciliée avec le combat
écologique parce que cette extension
progressive est mauvaise sur le plan
environnemental et donc le zéro
artificialisation net c'est un vrai
changement de l'organisation notre
urbanisme nos pratiques le second
phénomène a été la concentration des
terres si l'on résume nous nous trouvons
dans une solution dans une situation où
les agriculteurs qui partent à la
retraite ont tendance à vendre à leurs
voisins plutôt qu'à des jeunes au niveau
individuel c'est bien naturel on cède à
celui qu'on connaît au niveau collectif
en revanche l'effet peut parfois
s'avérer dramatique
si rien n'était fait dans cinq ans un
tiers des exploitations auront disparu
et la france ne comptera plus que 300
mille agriculteurs
c'est ça le mouvement naturel qui est le
nôtre
si rien n'est fait au niveau européen en
cinq ans nous n'aurons pas renouveler
notre capacité à produire aucun français
aucun européen ne souhaite cela c'est
pourquoi le prendrons des mesures fortes
pour faciliter l'accès au foncier pour
les jeunes agriculteurs
nous le prendrons d'abord dans le cadre
d'une loi foncière à venir nous
prendrons aussi cela en complément
d'autres mesures que nous souhaitons
mettre en oeuvre pour accompagner
l'installation et le développement des
jeunes agriculteurs et nous prendrons au
niveau européen
en intégrant cet enjeu dans le cadre des
négociations de la pac se souhaite enfin
que la pac favorise la constitution
d'une culture commune à tous les
agriculteurs du continent c'est
déterminant car ils vous l'avez compris
ce qui nous tient ce qui unit les
agriculteurs d'europe
par delà les spécificités nationales ce
sont des valeurs communes
un modèle qu'il ne faut jamais cesser de
cultiver et d'entretenir
c'est pourquoi un projet comme l'erasmus
farmers est si important et doit être
soutenue qui permettra aux jeunes futurs
agriculteurs de voyage et d'aller passer
un semestre une année dans un autre pays
européen pour y voir les techniques
agricoles les spécificités les bonnes
pratiques
on peut reproduire ne s'y connaître la
diversité de nos terroirs européens
comme doit être soutenu le sommet
international des jeunes agriculteurs qu
aura l'honneur d'accueillir paris en
avril prochain au cours duquel je suis
sûr que les jeunes agriculteurs d'europe
feront valoir leurs spécificités
cette culture commune est absolument
indispensable et est à bâtir
voilà donc mesdames et messieurs chers
amis ce qui doit nous guider une
exigence l'unité
et un triple promesses protéger
transformer anticipés tels sont les
piliers de l'europe agricole que nous
voulons alors si nous parvenons à tenir
ces trois promesses
l'europe sera plus forte et parce
qu'elle sera plus forte elle sera plus
audible elle sera plus crédible pour
défendre cette évidence que les produits
agricoles et alimentaires ne sont pas
des produits comme les autres pour
porter cette idée que protéger l'eau
l'air la terre
tous ces biens communs qui sont la
condition de toute culture doit être une
priorité de l'agenda international pour
dire avec force que nourrir 10 milliards
de femmes et d'hommes dans un contexte
de réchauffement climatique avec son
cortège de sécheresses d'inondations de
catastrophe naturelle dans un contexte
de perte de fertilité des sols est un
défi qu'il se relèvera pas par la seule
main invisible du marché ni par la loi
du plus fort
mais par le dialogue par un
multilatéralisme renouvelé par la
conscience lucide que nous avons en
partage la même planète
la responsabilité de son destin et celui
de l'humanité
au fond en matière agricole comme dans
de nombreux autres domaines
nous devons inventer un nouveau contrat
mondial
oui nous devons être à l'offensive en
portant une refonte profonde des règles
commerciales
je les ai évoqué il ya quelques mois en
exprimant devant l' ocde
ces règles conçues il ya près de 30 ans
sont devenus obsolètes et pour ce qui
est de l'agriculture elles conduisent à
une course au moins-disant
environnementale elle organise une quête
des prix bas qui met en péril tout à la
fois les droits sociaux les plus
élémentaires des travailleurs agricoles
leur santé et celle des consommateurs de
tout cela nous ne pouvons nous
accommoder dans une forme d' immobilisme
coupable
c'est pourquoi la france défend devant
l'om c'est la prise en compte des enjeux
sociaux et environnementaux comme
critère décisif
règles commerciales internationales
c'est pourquoi la france oeuvrent pour
que le codex alimentarius créé par les
nations unies et la haye fao puisse être
redynamisé est constitué pour tous les
pays du monde la grammaire commune d'une
alimentation et d'une agriculture saine
d'aucuns ne manqueront pas d'affirmer
que ces projets sont utopiques que le
multilatéralisme est une chimère qui
appartient au passé
les mêmes qui pensaient d'ailleurs que
le monde n'allait pas changer il ya
quelques années les mêmes qui pensaient
qu'il était impossible d'aller bloquer
les gens du numérique de les taxer vue
puisqu'il et les choses je les ai
entendus depuis longtemps faites moi
confiance que les gens qui vous disent
que c'est impossible ne vous encourage
qu'à une chose le faire encore plus vite
et plus fortement ce nouveau contre 1
mondial c'est celui que nous devons
bâtir
parce que nous aurons justement
construit une france agricole et
alimentaire forte et une europe agricole
plus forte
voilà mesdames et messieurs l'agenda que
je veux porter dans le cadre de la
présidence du g7
nous avons depuis le 1er janvier et qui
fait partie des grands sujets que nous
aurons à conduire dans les prochains
mois et que les ministres auront à
discuter avec leurs collègues
chers amis l'europe agricole telle que
je la conçois c'est celle que je viens
de vous exposer
je sais qu'elle dit aujourd'hui qu'elle
a peur je sais que plusieurs filières
aujourd'hui craignent un contexte
changeant
je sais que nos pêcheurs craignent les
effets du bric site
je veux le redire ici notre engagement
plein et entier n'avons pas choisi nous
peuple français c'est le choix souverain
du peuple britannique ses rangs des tout
à leur hommage à michel barnier
il défend l'intérêt commun européen et
dans ce contexte nous défendrons nos
pêcheurs
et dans intérêts nous défendrons toutes
nos filières avec force face à ces
changements subis mais plus largement
nous défendrons l'ensemble de nos
agriculteurs en ayant une europe qui
protège qui protège les peuples comme
les travailleurs une europe qui fait de
l'écologie et de la protection de
l'environnement une des priorité
cardinale une europe qui préparent
l'avenir qui cherche toujours à avoir un
temps d'avancé
consciente que le monde ne l'attend pas
et parce que l'agriculture est le miroir
des sociétés c'est aussi une europe qui
doit être fière de son histoire de ses
valeurs de ses terroirs qui défend un
rapport à la nature fondé sur le respect
qui défend une ruralité qui n'existe
nulle part ailleurs qu'ils ne cèdent
rien de cet art de vivre qui a toujours
été au coeur de notre identité
une europe qui porte haut finalement ce
modèle de civilisation qui la tient et
qui unit ces peuples
alors merci à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous pour l'engagement menée depuis
parfois plusieurs années au plusieurs
décennies pour cette agriculture
française et cette agriculture
européenne et merci pour les plus jeunes
d'avoir décidé d'embrasser ce métier
formidable ce métier non cette vocation
cette vie d'engagement de nourrir de
changer de protéger le contribuable
effet à cette aventure de nos paysages
de nos terres et du vivant qui est votre
engagement au quotidien
merci à toutes et tous vive la
république vive la france
et vive notre europe
merci commissaire et
ainsi à nos parlements créatrice très
bon goût
voilà pour ce discours d' emmanuel
macron le président de la république est
donc venu ce matin inaugurer ce 56e
salon de l'agriculture nous allons bien
sûr revenir longuement sur le discours
du chef de l'état avec nos trois invités
toujours sur ce plateau je voulais
représente patrick martin geniez
spécialiste des affaires européennes
auteur de l'europe at elle un avenir aux
éditions studyrama bruno parmentier
consultant sur les questions
d'agriculture et d'alimentation créateur
du blog nous nourrir manger point fr et
marcelo baisserait de journaliste
politique au figaro
on vient d'entendre le discours du
président de la république un discours
d'une heure et marcelo c'est vrai que
c'est un discours qui s'inscrit dans
cette campagne européenne
on a vu emmanuel macron président de la
république défenseur d'une europe
agricole oui et alors vous dites
campagne j'ai l'impression c'était
vraiment un président en campagne on
avait même un slogan l'europe qui
protège c'est une phrase qu'il a
utilisée il a peut-être d'ailleurs
utilisé le mot protéger au moins dix ou
quinze fois c'est à dire que on sent
bien que il est en train de préparer de
peaufiner un axe stratégique qui va être
celui de la protection jeu faites moi
confiance fait confiance à ma politique
je vous protégerait contre les ogm
le soja ogm de l'étranger contre les
blés russes contre les blés ukrainien
bref il est passé d'un discours qui
était vraiment on opposait les
souverainistes aux nationaux
progressistes les nationalistes aux
progressistes ga un discours dans
lesquels il se veut le protecteur de la
souveraineté européenne
c'est un vraiment un changement
stratégique on a vu à l'automne 2010 8
et là il est extrêmement claire dans ce
discours très offensif patrick martin
geniez vous l'avez aussi senti vous ce
président en campagne et c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron a eu une expression qui
est revenu très souvent dans ce discours
celle de politique agricole européenne
voilà ce qu'il veut construire le
président de la république il veut
reconstruire elle a même utilisé le
terme la refondation de l'europe mais
s'inscrit dans son projet de refondation
général de l'europe depuis qu'il est élu
président de la république est en effet
je rejoins tout à fait ce que vous avez
dit il a énormément parlé de protection
l'europe doit protéger
on l'avait bien vu dans la directive sur
les travailleurs détachés on doit
protéger les salariés français est
aujourd'hui les
sigean ce c'est la protection des
agriculteurs en france protection
patriotisme d'un patriotisme français
qui doit être compatible avec le
patriote de l'agriculture at il dit
voilà le patriote de l'agriculture
pourquoi parce que en réalité
évidemment on l'a pas évoquée c'est
qu'il ya des divisions au niveau
européen on est en passe de renégocier
la politique agricole européenne
on sait très bien qu'il y à des
divisions dans les pays européens il y a
les coups de butoir des états unis et de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
le projet de la commission européenne on
a le commissaire européen qui est
présent prévoit une baisse de 5 % du
budget consacré à la politique agricole
commune
donc il y à des divisions est en réalité
le président la république premièrement
est en campagne deuxièmement et lance un
appel à l'unité on va revenir longuement
sur cette question de la politique
agricole commune cette question de
l'europe mais bruno parmentier un mot
plus générale d'abord sur ce discours
c'est vrai qu'on a vu emmanuel macron
qui s'est voulue défenseurs d'une france
forte mais dans une europe agricole
forte
oui défenseur de l'agriculture aussi
parce que soyons clair c'était pas son
truc l'agriculture dans la campagne
présidentielle il en a très peu parlé
et puis il a probablement une erreur de
casting il est obligé de changer son
ministre de l'agriculture au bout d'un
an et demi et puis bon on avait
l'impression que il hésitait entre
l'écologie et l'agriculture etc
et là on voit que il a pris conscience
de l'importance fondamentale de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation du défi
environnemental et que pour toutes ces
choses là
la france elle est toute petite il faut
absolument une nouvelle frontière
européenne là dessus et donc c'est un
vrai discours programme parce que il
avait organisé les états généraux en
disant bas il faut sauvegarder un peu en
donnant un peu plus de de revenus aux
agriculteurs
et là on sent qu'il se dit ils nous font
une vraie politique agricole et cette
vraie politique agricole elle commence
par les élections européennes parce
qu'elle ne peut passer que par une
politique européenne
alors on va revenir longuement sur ce
discours mais on va aussi suivre les
premières
réactions du monde politique et des
agriculteurs à ce discours des manuels
macron grâce à vous tanne traduire
bonjour tab
vous êtes en compagnie de nicolas giraud
qui est le secrétaire national de la
confédération paysanne
oui nicolas gibon vous n'avez pas été
convaincu par le discours du président
de la république pouvez vous me dire
pourquoi pas nous il nous semble relaxer
c'est un discours quand même disons le
discours qui fait aujourd'hui en
ouverture du salon notamment il devait
parler de la jeunesse il devait parler
la politique agricole commune quelle
vision on a il nous ressert comme ce
qu'il allait faire un geste les
objectifs de transition agricole de
changement de modèle
sauf que il l'a servi à rungis ensuite
les états généraux de l'alimentation est
la loi
non pas du tout avancé là dessus donc ce
serait le moment de poser des actes plus
co2 plutôt que de servir un discours sur
cette thématique là est sûre sur la
formation des jeunes ou sur la nécessité
de d'avancé sur plus d'emplois paysans
on n'est pas du tout au niveau de ce
qu'on attendait dans ce discours là pour
nous la pac futur qui doit arriver doit
avoir comme enjeu de non seulement
renouveler les générations mais deux
mais de permettre à plus de paysannes et
paysans d'être présent sur les
territoires français et européens il ya
quand même eu des éléments dans lux
cours des manuels macron notamment sur
la question environnementale lorsqu'il a
dit qu'il fallait pouvoir anticiper
miser sur la recherche ça ça ne vous a
pas convaincu
bon après miser sur la recherche
anticipe et voilà c'est c'est vachement
flou quand il parle de protection
il a beaucoup parlé d'assurance donc
nous c'est quelque chose qui nous
convient pas parce que ça va sarah
pomper énormément d'argent de la pac qui
devrait servir la transition qui devrait
servir l'emploi et qui dans ce cas là va
servir les assurances et ça s à nous on
estime que ça peut pas fonctionner et
après niveau de la recherche
il nous semble que on peut pas tout
confié à la recherche il faut faire
confiance au monde paysan faire
confiance au savoir faire au métier de
paysan comme on est capable de le faire
évoluer comme incapable de le pratiquer
et ça c'est pas la laisser pas forcément
la recherche qui va donner ces bilans
mais pour ça il faut il faut redonner
les clés aux paysans et il faut redonner
les moyens d'installer du monde et deux
aides avancées en ce sens là il ya eu
aussi des mots adressés à la jeunesse a
sur la question de l'accession au
foncier en fait que c'est aujourd'hui le
principal frein d'installation pour les
jeunes agriculteurs
alors que c'est important alors que 50 %
des agriculteurs vont partir à la
retraite dans les cinq prochaines années
ça non plus vous n'êtes pas convaincu
balala encore envahi il reprend les mots
qu'on était sorti du débat parlementaire
pour aboutir à une loi foncière sauf que
quand on échange avec le ministre quand
on échange a crevé dans l'assemblée
nationale nous explique que cette loi
foncière ils savent pas quand elle va
arriver ils savent pas si elle va
arriver donc là bon emmanuel macron
semble pointer la nécessité d'une loi
sur le foncier nous ça ça nous convient
mais il va falloir encore une fois
qu'elles sont ambitieuses qu'elle
réponde à ces enjeux là et c'est pas le
tout de le dire aujourd'hui pour
qu'ensuite ce soit détricoté par les
milices par les parlementaires et qu'on
arrive à une loi foncière qui ne
permettent pas justement de réinstaller
du monde parce que en effet c'est le
gros problème l'accès au foncier si on
veut arriver à avoir des paysans plus
nombreux il faut forcément être capable
de partager le foncier mais pour ça il
va falloir mettre des contraintes et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on n'entend pas dans
le discours d' emmanuel macron c'est la
possibilité de contraindre ceux qui ceux
qui n'arrivent pas à faire fonctionner
le monde paysan ce qui arrive pas le
faire évoluer
et ça ça ça manque cruellement merci
beaucoup nicolas giraud d'avoir répondu
à mes questions les discours du
président de la république en ouverture
de ce salon dont donc pas convaincu la
confédération paysanne
merci beaucoup ta mais on revient bien
sûr vers vous un tout au long de cette
édition spéciale pour de nouvelles
réactions politiques
marcelo peut-être un petit mot avec vous
on entend la confédération paysanne
alors ce n'est qu'une première réaction
en aura d'autres évidemment ce n'est pas
représentatif des réactions que de tous
les agriculteurs mais on sont une
déception est ce qu'en faisant un
discours européen qui s'adresse à
l'europe à ses partenaires européens
bien emmanuel macron a manqué de
convaincre les agriculteurs français
surtout de répondre à leurs
préoccupations quotidiennes
moi ce que m'inspire cette réaction
c'est que l illustre bien le fait que
emmanuel macron s'adresse dans ce
discours à deux publics différents
il ya le public des agriculteurs mais à
travers son adresse aux agriculteurs il
a un message à la france rurale et à la
france tout court
par exemple sur la question de
l'environnement on voit bien que la
crise des gilet jaune est passé par là
c'est à dire qu'il a un discours qui
n'est plus de l'écologie qu'on a pu
qualifier punitive mais quelque chose où
il est en flat
l'agriculteur comme étant un protecteur
de la nature
un éleveur passionné soucieux du
bien-être de ses bêtes et donc on a on
sent bien qu'il essaie d'imprimer un
discours qui soit un discours de
protection à l'égard de la population
française et qui ne soit pas un discours
du haut vers le bas c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup reproché dans cette crise des
gilet jaune dans lequel paris donne des
instructions sur ce qu'il est bon de
faire et de ne pas faire et donc il ya
peut-être de deux publics et donc un
public qui peut être lui déçu parce
qu'il attend des choses précises et un
public plus large qui lui a entendu
notre musique à moi avec vous patrick
martin geniez sur cette première
réaction peut-être des agriculteurs déçu
est ce que le discours d' emmanuel
macron correspondait à leurs attentes
côté je crois que c'est un peu tôt alors
je vais vu un représentant de la
confédération nationale des agriculteurs
dire je suis déçu certes mais le présent
la république un discours très fort et
vous le disiez en s'adressant à l'europe
il s'adresse aussi aux agriculteurs
français
et si on annonce une loi foncière vous
savez qu'ils organisent il y ait un
organisme aujourd'hui qui s'appelle la
safer il est urgent aujourd'hui de
lutter contre la spéculation foncière
c'est effectivement le point
d'achoppement les jeunes agriculteurs ne
peut plus s'installer parce que le
terrain coûte trop cher il faut donc je
n'ai et la spéculation
lorsque vous allez dans les régions en
france on voit bien qu'il ya une sorte
de mitage urbain et que ça coûte de plus
en plus cher pour s'installer
par conséquent ce qu'il ya une loi
foncière c'est un élément très important
et il y à un appel à l'europe parce que
il y a une différence de culture vous
disiez tout à l'heure
il ya certains pays qui sont bien plus
libéraux qui va l'être moins
protectionnistes et donc il ya un appel
à la protection des agriculteurs
il ya un langage très fort alors
pourquoi être déçu tout de suite
peut-être mais je pense que si le
président de la république le ministre
de l'agriculture tiennent leurs
promesses
on peut avoir une loi foncière qui
permettent dans les années qui viennent
aux jeunes agriculteurs de s'installer
alors on va revenir sur l'un des temps
forts de ce discours du président de la
république
il a parlé de la pac la politique
agricole commune dont les négociations
sont en cours une pac qui va baisser
pour les prochaines années
emmanuel macron
un message il va falloir réinventer la
pas qu'on l'ait coûte donc oui notre
défi ça n'est pas simplement comme le
voudraient certains de liquider
l'héritage de plus de 60 ans de
politique agricole commune de céder au
poison lent de la division et c'est bien
de réinventer cette politique agricole
commune
aujourd'hui et c'est pour moi une
question de souveraineté de souveraineté
alimentaire environnementale industriels
c'est à dire de pouvoir faire en tant
que citoyen européen
nos choix et que la jeunesse européenne
puisse les faire si nous cédons à
l'esprit de division alors dans cinq ans
dans dix ans dans 15 ans nous ne
pourront plus garantir à nos concitoyens
une alimentation saine en tout cas
totalement traçable et indépendante en
europe nous ne pourront plus garantir la
cohérence d'une politique
environnementale nous imposeront à nos
producteurs des normes de plus en plus
dur mais nous serons dépendants
d'intrants ou d'un port de puissance qui
ne respecteront pas les mêmes règles et
nous laisseront ainsi s'effriter des
filières de l'emploi des territoires qui
dépendent de la force de cette politique
commune aucun agriculteur aucun
consommateur ne souhaite demain être
soumis aux normes au standard au prix et
finalement au diktat des non européens
bruno parmentier vous avez entendu le
président de la république a parlé de la
pac de réinventer la pac peut-être avant
de revenir sur ce qu'il a dit est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire pour que ce soit
clair pour nos téléspectateurs que
représente la pac aujourd'hui alors la
pac au démarrage on aurait dû l'appeler
la politique alimentaire commune quand
on a imaginé cette politique
on sortait des tickets de rationnement
il ya eu des tickets de rationnement
france jusqu'en 1948
je veux dire le préfet de police fixer
lui-même le prix de la baguette de pain
faut voir il y avait quand même une
angoisse fondamentale de manquer et donc
la population a dit il faut absolument
avoir un approvisionnement régulier
stable sécurisé et de nourriture et puis
on pourrait aussi dire que c'est une
politique industrielle commune
curieusement c'est que il a fallu pour
garder de l'industrie il a fallu donner
enfin offrir de la nourriture pas cher
et avec la pac vont se rendre compte que
le supermarché nous vend la nourriture à
moitié prix on paye la moitié de
nourriture à la caissière du supermarché
et l'autre moitié sous forme d'impôts et
le percepteur à travers l'europe donne
des subventions à l'agriculteur pour
qu'ils puissent vendre à la coopérative
sa production en dessous des coûts de
production ce qui permet d'avoir à la
fois un approvisionnement pas cher pour
maintenir des salaires qui permettent de
conserver de l'industrie et en même
temps avoir une politique agricole avec
des agriculteurs
mais ceci dit quand on commence la pac
il ya environ 6 millions d'agriculteurs
aujourd'hui il y en a 500 milles la pac
sa sortie 5 millions 500 mille
agriculteurs et l'air du temps c'est
qu'il commence par dire cette fois ci on
va protéger et dit clairement il ya 500
mais l'agriculteur on peut très bien en
avoir plus de 300000 donc là on atteint
vraiment le fond il faut absolument
protégé pour protéger le consommateur
faut protéger
alors je ne suis pas sûr qu'on revienne
à un million d'agriculteurs
heures mais cette idée dire protégeant
ceux qui sont là et ton renouvellement
est tombé à cette transformation
c'est un vrai changement culturel parce
que macron c'était le président start up
donc on s'attendait ce qui parle
transformation anticipation et quelque
part il devient aussi président pères de
la nation en disant oui mais quand même
on va protéger aussi donc il essaie de
rééquilibrer les choses on va revenir
sur cette politique agricole commune et
on va tout de suite retourné dans les
années du salon avec vous tapez traduit
pour une autre réaction celle de samuel
vandales secrétaire général des jeunes
agriculteurs
oui samuel 20 dalle vous avez été plutôt
convaincu 1 par le discours du président
de la république un discours très riche
et qui a été porté bien sûr par une
forte dimension européenne
oui alors convaincu que c'est beaucoup
dire le président de la république a eu
un message assez fort pour les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs sont les
gens pragmatiques donc ils sont
convaincus que quand ils voyent du
résultat un discours européen fort pour
une europe forte avec un budget à la
hauteur des attentes des agriculteurs et
des concitoyens en faisant vraiment le
lien avec cette alimentation de qualité
saine sur durable au niveau repeint un
point très important sur l'installation
renouvellement des générations où le
président la république a mis en avant
que un tiers des agriculteurs pourraient
partir à la retraite d'ici cinq ans et
donc on pourrait perdre un tiers de nos
exploitants donc il faut une vraie
politique à l'installation ambitieuse au
niveau français et au niveau européen
une vraie politique sur ce sujet là
aussi une politique sur l'importation de
nos produits étrangers une bataille fort
qu'il a envie de mener se dire on ne
doit plus faire rentrer des produits qui
ne corrompt correspondent pas aux
standards alimentaire européen et c'est
important de se battre pour la sécurité
alimentaire de nos concitoyens donc un
sujet important pour nous beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets ont été
abordés
une heure de discours on s'attendait
peut-être un petit peu moins étant donné
le calendrier de la visite beaucoup
beaucoup de sujets ont été évoqués très
prenant très incitant il a incité
énormément sur l'image de l'agriculteur
et des agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui est
un peu mise à mal par tout un tas
d'associations et de dire qu'aujourd'hui
a notamment parlé de la grille bashing
actuelle et la question de la
maltraitance animale
tout à fait et il a dit il a lu un
discours assez fort en disant mais qui
mieux qu'un agriculteur pour soigner ces
animaux quand un éleveur se lève la nuit
pour un vêlage il le fait pour le bon
sens pour ces animaux c'est pour le
bien-être et donc il faut qu'on en soit
convaincu et il veut nous aider aussi
aller dans ce sens là pour l'image des
agriculteurs
l'essentiel de son discours c'était
aussi de dire qu'il fallait une
politique agricole commune forte bien
sûr avec un budget important
on sait que ça peut poser problème avec
les briques site qui s'annonce et
d'ailleurs est dans le fait qu'il y ait
michel barnier est le négociateur du
break site
eh bien c'était quand même un vrai point
important dans cette salle tout à
l'heure oui la panique et la difficulté
qu'il ya aujourd'hui avec le break site
il a bien sûr citer michel barnier aux
côtés de phil hogan le commissaire
européen où on doit trouver des
solutions
mais en attendant c'est pas parce qu'il
ya le mexique break site qu'il faut
qu'on baisse les bras il faut qu'on
continue il faut qu'on avance et c'est
le message qu'il a voulu dévoiler entre
autres aussi sur la gestion des risques
voilà prévenir de la gestion des risques
qu'ils soient économiques qui soient
sociales qu'ils soient climatique il
faut accompagner les agriculteurs et les
exploitations à mieux prévenir des
risques climatiques sociaux et
économiques avec il a reparlé dit on
verra quel système à mettre en place est
ce que c'est des quotas est que ces
dérégulation ce qui s'est déjà fait donc
on attend de voir
on attend du concret aujourd'hui pour
les agriculteurs français merci beaucoup
samuel vandales d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup tablent pour cette
nouvelle réaction alors qu'on le voit
sur ces images en direct des allées du
salon la visite du président de la
république se poursuit et vous le voyez
bien ils sont nombreux à attendre le
passage du chef de l'état qui je le
rappelle a prévu de passer de longues
heures
ici au salon on va revenir sur cette
question de la pac 1 patrick martin
geniez on en parlait les négociations de
la pac
elles sont actuellement en cours voilà
alors simplement revenir sur la
signification de la pac à l'origine
c'est une créature de la commune et
européennes si vous passez d'expression
l'objectif c'était l'autosuffisance
alimentaire en europe et ça on peut dire
que l'objectif est atteint même s'il est
remis en cause avec tous les évènements
enfin tous les événements cacit emmanuel
macron et la concurrence internationale
des deux amants stabiliser le revenu des
agriculteurs
il faut savoir que la pax est environ
entre 55 et 60 milliards d'euros par an
les agriculteurs donc ils comptent
essentiellement sur les aides des
subventions de l'union européenne et si
aujourd'hui on diminue ses subventions
c'est aussi une détresse supplémentaire
pour les agriculteurs qui veulent se
maintenir
et donc comme vous le dites tout à fait
justement aujourd'hui on est en cours la
pac
enfin la politique agricole commune
européenne est en voie de renégociation
pourquoi parce qu'on renégocie le
programme pluri financiers annuels
jusqu'en 2027 et la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que la commission fait
des propositions mais on ne sait pas si
le parlement européen va pouvoir voter
ses propositions d'ici le mois de mai
car comme vous savez il ya des élections
et cela pourrait impacter en effet le
fameux budget et donc on est en pleine
négociation et aujourd'hui il ne faut
pas jeudi dernier les difficultés les
divisions au niveau de l'union
européenne ue avec le président de la
république a fait un appel à l'unité
il ya ceux qui veulent détruire l'europe
sur le plan national on entend
clairement des partis politiques qui
lisait parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
entendu emmanuel macron parler de ce
poison de la division une visée quel
pays bas et les pays de l'est européen
la pologne le groupe devises au grade
mais également des pays du nord comme le
pays bas le danemark qui n'ont pas la
même approche que nous qui sont bien
plus libéraux alors que la france est
bien plus interventionniste il faut que
savoir donc il ya des divisions sur ce
plan est par exemple on a parlé du
glyphosate
alors on a dit on va réduire à trois ans
il faut savoir que l'allemagne ne nous a
pas suivis sur ce point en 2017 car
l'allemagne a voté dans le comité des
experts pour la reconduction pour cinq
ans du glyphosate
donc il ya vraiment des divisions et il
faut aujourd'hui un appel à l'unité
et c'est pour ça c'est le sens du
discours du président de la république
et je crois qu'effectivement il faut que
la france maintienne le cap
la france doit maintenir le cap en dit
patrick martin geniez c'est aussi ce que
dit l'elysée ce que dit le président de
la république on va se battre pour
préserver le budget de la pac est ce que
la france peut y arriver
mais oui parce que beaucoup de gens dans
averti pourrait imaginer que c'est quand
même très cher de dépenser des dizaines
de milliards pour l'agriculteur qui est
un truc ringard du 19e et du 20e siècle
mais en fait on paye pas ce qu'on veut
des choses contradictoires
on veut que les gens et de la nourriture
pas cher et donc si on l'a juste la
nourriture pas cher l'agriculture
européenne disparaît puisque à plein de
gens qui font ça pour moins cher que nos
mais on veut les meilleures normes
environnementales et les meilleures
normes sanitaires et on veut que ce soit
produit chez nous et en plus on veut des
lois sociales des revenus avec des lois
sociales donc c'est complètement
contradictoire si on veut tous à la fois
et chacune de ces choses est
parfaitement légitime
il faut payer ça s'appelle la politique
agricole commune donc on achète
effectivement un art de vivre européens
et en particulier en france un art de
vivre un française auquel on tient qui
est vraiment constitutif de notre
culture
donc si on veut toucher à la fois faut
payer et en europe
il ya plein de gens qui disent mais
c'est pas grave aller par exemple
l'angleterre en permanence disait ça le
commonwealth et grands bon moi je ne
suis pas sûr qu avoir dû l'être nouvelle
zélande pour le petit déjeuner le matin
dans un monde extrêmement et sécuriser
ce soit durable sain et sécurisé qui a
des éleveurs laitiers à moins de 100 km
de chez moi
mais c'est ensuite puisque vous parlez y
est puisque vous parlez de l'angleterre
le bric site c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle pour la pac
bah écoute est en tous les cas du point
de vue idéologique
l'angleterre elle a toujours été pour
éviter de faire des politiques communes
et donc quelque part ça renforce la
politique des gens qui disent il faut
quand même s'organiser si on veut manger
manger sûrement et manger durablement
bon alors maintenant c'est à nos grands
clients faut pas oublier que si on
restreint
si on n'est plus dans l'europe nous
sommes un pays massivement exportateurs
de pays de produits agricoles
il va falloir quand même vendre nos
produits on est d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
il l'a dit on est concurrencés par par
d'autres mais globalement la france est
un très grand pays agricole elle a
besoin de l'europe et donc je suis
confiant que pendant quelques mois avec
l'angleterre
sarr est compliqué mais c'était un
exemple bien besoin de nos fruits et
légumes et revenir par nos les acheter
et nous dans les négociations
européennes les gens très guillemets
raisonnable un peu interventionniste qui
veulent vraiment une politique à long
terme
seront plus nombreux dans les
négociations européennes alors on
parlait de ce poison de la division et
bruno parmentier marcelo parlais à
l'instant de cette concurrence parce que
c'est le message qu'a voulu délivrer
emmanuel macron attention en matière
d'agriculture la concurrence elle n'est
pas entre les pays européens elle est à
l'extérieur emmanuel macron lance un
appel à l'europe
il faut s'unir pour lutter contre la
concurrence externe oui alors c'est on
se souvient que emmanuel macron avec
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir décider
d'être une sorte de champion de la cause
européenne et qu' il n'avait pas trouvé
la bonne porte d'entrée et que son âge
il avait tendu la main à l'allemagne
mais l'allemagne a vu les difficultés
qu'on connaît
il avait tenté d'être on va dire à la
pointe de de l'europe progressiste
contre le groupe devise grad contre les
tentations populistes
ça n'avait pas fonctionné il tente une
troisième version
un troisième logiciel qui est celui de
la protection ont fait bloc contre la
menace extérieure et c'est vrai que
c'est une porte d'entrée qui est
beaucoup plus simple et sans doute
beaucoup plus efficace et qui a le
mérite aussi d'être audible au niveau
national patrick martin geniez cette
concurrence extérieure
elle menace bien évidemment l'union
européenne qui va devoir s'unir pour y
faire face oui tout à fait et on veut
détruire l'union européenne de
l'extérieur c'est très clair c'est le
cas de dalal trump des états unis
regardez ce qui se passe
il veut qu'on passe allègrement sur la
sécurité alimentaire surtout les normes
sanitaires et c'est à des objectifs de
la politique agricole commune
il va absolument importés il veut taxer
des produits aux etats-unis ont fait
face également à la russie à la chine
donc on doit faire bloc pour cela car
nous avons une industrie agroalimentaire
une agriculture de qualité et on le voit
bien on voit bien ce qu'il ya un vrai
malaise aujourd'hui à bruxelles c'est le
poids des lobbys aller le poids des
lobbys à la commission européenne
et on voit bien qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de lutter contre certains
experts qui ne sont pas indépendants 1
qui sont des experts des industries
agroalimentaires éventuellement des
états unis donc là il ya un véritable
risque c'est qu'on diminue la qualité et
notamment la qualité des consommations
pour les consommateurs la qualité des
produits agricoles et donc ça c'est très
important
il faut donc ne pas se diviser la
question aujourd'hui elle est politique
est ce que la france a les moyens
d'avoir un entraînement sur l'europe on
voit bien qu'avec les difficultés
tout est rencontré par le président de
la république la france est affaiblie
l'allemagne est elle même très affaibli
en gueule à merkel et au crépuscule de
sa vie politique qu'est ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on va être
capable d'insuffler une vraie
refondation de la politique agricole en
europe et c'est la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie question à
marcelo 1 est ce que la france a le
poids nécessaire
c'est vrai face à une allemagne qui est
affaibli et peut-être qu emmanuel macron
aussi et plus sain faibli en interne
qu'il ne l'était au début de son mandat
quand il se voulait le grand leader de
l'europe
c'était le pari effectivement d'emmanuel
macron et il a eu il a fait un pari à un
moment où le contexte politique en
europe a changé et des essais donc
retrouvé en fait relativement tout seul
puisque très rapidement angela merkel
s'est retrouvé isolé dans sa coalition
très rapidement les populismes l'otan
porté dans un certain nombre de
démocraties européennes et emmanuel
macron lui même sur la scène politique
intérieure s'est retrouvé affaibli
puisqu'il est rentré dans une phase
d'impopularité très rapidement qu'il a
eu un moment un espoir de rebond puis
les retombées et donc il doit
aujourd'hui trouver une autre
formulation et c'est ce qu'ils
s'emploient à faire mais on voit bien
que là on est dans une phase de campagne
il ya des des profils politiques qui
sont meilleurs dans la conquête du
pouvoir que dans l'exercice du pouvoir
là on est dans un autre exercice
il est en campagne donc là la question
de son bilan on la laisse un peu de côté
et il promet la route beaucoup utilisé
la question la promesse je vous promets
en promet etc
elle saura t-il saura-t-il faire naître
un peu cet espoir qui est typique des
phases électorale on verra bruno
parmentier
oui je pense que il ya aussi une chose
nouvelle qu'on savait mais les
politiques ne parlait jamais qu'elles
étaient pendant ce ropéenne et là
notamment citer deux dépendances
extrêmement préoccupante la dépendance
au soja d'amérique latine et la
déférence au phosphore il faut se rendre
compte que tous nos animaux marche du
soja d'argentine et du brésil
la france a décolonisé l'europe à
décoloniser on va dire
le soja que nous importons pour nourrir
nos animaux couvre en amérique
l'équivalent de la superficie agricole
la france carrément donc eu un plan
protéines pour dire c'est pas possible
de dire nous on fait des céréales mais
les protéines on les importe d'amérique
latine
c'est absolument décisif pour
l'indépendance de l'europe
et puis le phosphore nous arrivons à la
fin des gisements mondiaux de phosphore
le phosphore va devenir un élément
extrêmement important il faut absolument
trouver une agriculture qui deviennent
plus indépendantes de ses points de vue
là en europe
et sans ces deux dossiers nouveaux qui
sont peut-être un peu technique mais qui
sont fondamentaux pour l'avenir de
l'europe et on ne s'en sortira pas tout
seul sur ces dossiers là exactement
comme le dossier du réchauffement
climatique
il ya des choses aux il faut avoir
suffisamment de taille pour pouvoir
réagir
alors il ya eu un autre thème fort du
discours du président de la république
c'est l'environnement l'écologie est
d'ailleurs le président de la république
l'a dit patrick martin geniez dans la
future pac
eh bien il faudra une part consacrée à
l'environnement il faudra une part
substantielle même je crois que l'adie
50% la moitié des aides
il faut savoir que le budget de la
politique agricole commune c'était plus
de 60% au début maintenant elle a
diminué considérablement
et donc il ya deux éléments dans le
budget européen la politique agricole
commune et la politique de cohésion et
dans la politique agricole européenne
effectivement il faut réorienter les
aides et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
qu'on parle d'une nouvelle définition
des critères d aide et c'est ça la
difficulté aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
menace aujourd'hui derrière cela c'est
que si elle volonté de la france par
exemple ce n'est pas forcément la
volonté des autres états européens on
parle de redéfinir les critères des
aides mais de redonner une subsidiarité
aux états c'est une marge de manoeuvre à
chaque cas pour définir les thèmes
environnementaux et cela est à 20 risque
politique car il ya des risques de
renationalisation de la politique
agricole qui pourrait mettre en menace
effectivement la politique européenne
l'exigence environnementale c'est très
bien le président de la république a
parlé de la biodiversité
mais on sent très bien que la bid et de
la biodiversité est en diminution et
donc les rendements agricoles dont il ya
des vrais contradictions sur ce point
est donc effectivement c'est un autre
risque mais il faut absolument
réorienter mais si on axait on
l'accent sur l'environnement il faut
aussi définir de nouveaux critères par
exemple dire et bien définir les aide
plus importante en fonction du nombre de
la population qui travaille sur un
terrain alors il ya un sujet quand on
parle d'environnement d'écologie en
matière d'agriculture c'est le
glyphosate emmanuel macron on a bien sûr
parlé la france qui se veut en pointe en
europe sur la sortie du glyphosate et le
chef de l'état a redit son objectif de
vouloir sortir du glyphosate plus
rapidement possible on écoute
cela ne vous a pas échappé le grand
débat national a remis sur la table
beaucoup de sujets que notre pays a vécu
ces derniers mois ou ces dernières
années qui touche en notre capacité
collective à anticiper pour n'en citer
qu'un la sortie du glyphosate
j'ai rappelé récemment c'était je crois
en drôme monsieur ministre ma volonté
sortir du glyphosate le plus rapidement
possible sous trois ans et il ne faut
pas voir cet objectif comme une
contrainte
et il ne faut pas tomber à l'égard de
cet objectif sous de faux débat c'est au
contraire une opportunité
l'opportunité pour de nombreuses
filières d'évoluer profondément
rappelez-nous d'abord d'où nous venions
nous partions en fin d'année 2010 est
vers 10 ans de renouvellement
d'autorisation du glyphosate même quinze
ans au départ la france s'est mobilisée
nous nous sommes battus pour faire voter
au niveau européen cinq années est ce
que nous voulons faire nous c'est faire
mieux par an sur transposant c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris donc pas en
passant dans la loi une contrainte qui
aurait créé une différence par rapport à
nos voisins mais en montrant dans les
faits que nous pouvons le faire en trois
ans par la mobilisation collectif par
des solutions construites filière par
filière je pense très profondément que
nous pouvons y arriver
je pense d'ailleurs très profondément
que nous sommes en train d' enclencher
la dynamique qui nous permettra d'y
arriver
marcelo baez fred emmanuel macron et
bien veut faire de la france veut
montrer que la france est en pointe sur
cette sortie du glyphosate
oui alors j'avoue que ce point là m'a
surpris dans son dans son discours
puisque on sait que les chefs de l'état
quand ils viennent dans ce salon de
l'agriculture ils ont plutôt tendance à
souvenez vous un nicolas sarkozy
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
en général c'est le moment où les
présidents de la république m quelques
bémols pour faire passer un peu la
pilule d'un discours environnemental
auprès des agriculteurs là c'est vrai
qu'il a été il n'a pas du tout été dans
l'écologie punitive dont la tonalité
était plutôt qu'à violente pour les
agriculteurs mais il a maintenu sa
promesse tel quel de sortir le plus
rapidement possible sous trois ans du
glyphosate il à mains nues alors que ses
ministres
comment déjà dit s'il est une petite
musique un peu différente pour préparer
les mentalités au fait qu' on n'arrivera
pas à 100% de sortie du glyphosate dans
trois ans alors certains nous disent oui
alors pour les vignes qui sont sur les
seuls en pente ce sera compliqué
d'autres nous disent à 90% le fera à 70%
à 80%
on sent bien que là il a senti le danger
il n'a pas ouvrir pas voulu ouvrir la
boîte de pandore parce que s'il avait
reculé aujourd'hui on aurait parlé et
retenu que ça de son discours
et c'est vrai bruno parmentier que le
président de la république a aussi dit
sortir du glyphosate d'accord mais il ya
eu un problème de recherche il ya eu un
problème d'anticipation il ya un
problème d'innovation on ne peut pas
sortir si facilement que ça du
glyphosate
ah oui il faut se rendre compte comme le
problème des mauvaises herbes
empoisonnent la vie des agriculteurs
depuis 3000 ans 1
c'est un énorme problème faux pas du
tout le négliger parce que du coup
d'ailleurs les mauvaises un taux bien
plus coriace si j'ose dire que les
bonnes parce que avec tout ce qu'on les
a maltraité depuis 3000 ans elles sont
encore là et finalement on les a brûlés
on les enfouit avec le labour où on les
empoisonner bon ben finalement tout ça
c'est pas terrible brûlé c'est mauvais
pour le réchauffement climatique
le labour c'est un désastre finalement
et pour la planète
finalement il faut absolument arrêter le
labour et c'est très compliqué et les
produits chimiques c'est compliqué alors
c'est pas du tout le produit chimique le
plus cancérogènes jeudi les insecticides
sont bien plus dangereux pour l'homme
ils sont conçus pour tous les insectes
que les herbicides
mais il paye pour tout le monde c'est
j'ose dire parce qu'il est très connu il
ya eu l'arrogance de monsanto et caetera
et donc trouver un moyen de se passer à
la fois de brûler d'empoisonner et de
labourer
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est des
mélanges de plantes en fait il va
falloir cultiver son herbicide c'est à
dire mettre des plantes qui poussent
avant les autres qui couvrent le sol qui
empêchent les autres de poussins et qui
ont le bon goût de geler l'hiver pour
laisser la place bon on va tâtonner
c'est très compliqué il ya des filières
où c'est plus facile que d'autres et
donc du jour au lendemain dire ce
produit là à la mauvaise cote il faut
l'arrêter c'est très compliqué on veut
aussi manger tout doux ce qu'a dit le
président de la république un patrick
martin je n'y ai que la clé c'est
l'anticipation par la recherche et par
l'innovation européenne
tout à fait et d'ailleurs le budget
recherche et innovation de l'union
européenne va augmenter considérablement
de 50 % et dans ce budget recherche
innovation il y aura une part consacrée
à l'agriculture sur le glyphosate mais
vous avez tout à fait raison
énormément d'agriculteurs sont victimes
de cancers dus à ces pesticides
donc lorsqu'on parle de renouvellement
de la population agricole faut aussi
voir quelles sont les exigences de santé
publique et la joie que les agriculteurs
sont tout à fait d'accord là car ils
connaissent ce genre de difficultés
simplement il faut des instruments
qu'ils soient tout à fait efficace de la
transition écologique
c'est à dire qu on réoriente les
critères dead de subventions aux
agriculteurs de façon à faire une
répartition équitable entre la
production et la préservation de
l'environnement
et ça c'est à la france de se battre au
niveau de l'union européenne pour avoir
des critères plus équitable alors direct
sur sur les images le début de la
déambulation des manuels macron dans les
allées du
l'on à la rencontre des visiteurs le
chef de l'état qui va rencontrer les
visiteurs mais aussi les professionnels
et de nombreuses filières tout au long
de la journée on parler de cette
question de l'environnement et est que
finalement cette question sa difficulté
à concilier agriculture et environnement
elle y est pour beaucoup dans la grille
bashing qu'on voit en ce moment la lutte
contre la grille bashing c'est la
volonté de l'elysée c'est la volonté du
ministre de l'agriculture c'est un petit
peu le thème du salon cette année
oui c'est qu'un tas côté les les
français aiment les agriculteurs et
d'ailleurs les centaines de milliers de
personnes qui viennent chaque année au
salon de l'agriculture que quelque part
on a une relation charnelle
tout le monde a un grand père un arrière
grand père agriculteur on a gardé ça et
puis dans l'autre côté effectivement on
a artificialisés le conflit entre les
écolos et les agriculteurs ce qui est
quand même très fort sur le fond les
premiers écolos c'est quand même ce qui
de son furent terrain etc
ils sont faits publics je n'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un commune en désignant la
planète qu'un agriculteur est donc en
fait il faut concilier les exigences de
production avec les contraintes
nouvelles et les contraintes nouvelles
c'est le réchauffement climatique qui
rend beaucoup plus compliqué les choses
il va falloir produire malgré le
réchauffement climatique
il nous fallait produire sans réchauffer
la planète et il va falloir à la fois
produire et refroidir la planète
c'est-à-dire remixée du carbone dans nos
sols
c'est ce qu'il appelle le 4 pour mille
etc c'est un enjeu absolument
considérable pour lequel il faut
absolument soutenir les agriculteurs et
pour le moment on les accuse t fait si
tu fais ci fais pas ci fais pas ça et en
fait faut créer une dynamique
d'expérimentation d'innovation
collective pour pouvoir résoudre à la
fois ce problème de produire et de
protéger la planète et marseille
auraient secrète cette difficulté à
concilier agriculture et écologie c'est
aussi un enjeu de politique interne pour
emmanuel macron oui alors souvenons nous
que il n'a jamais été très branché sur
l'écologie mais
quand ils arrivent au pouvoir ils réussi
cet exploit que personne n'avait réussi
avant lui aucun président il fait venir
la star de l'écologie nicolas hulot
quelqu'un qu'on connaît pour ses
discours idéaliste militants etc mais
peu ouvert on va dire à l'art du
compromis et donc pendant plusieurs mois
il a dû essayer d'avancer avec un
ministre de l'écologie qui sans arrêt
était à deux doigts de lui que de
claquer la porte et de s'en aller et il
a essayé de trouver une sorte de ligne
de craie dans laquelle ils avançaient
sur des sur le plan environnemental mais
en même temps avec avec un discours qui
était pas forcément bien reçu on a eu le
départ de nicolas audio on a eu la crise
des gilet jaune sur la question de la
fiscalité écologique
aujourd'hui il remet tout à plat avec un
discours on voit bien c'est à l'europe
de rémunérer les activités écologistes
des agriculteurs at il dit tout à
l'heure en substance c'est un changement
de paradigme où vous nous parler du
ministre de l'écologie a très rapidement
avec vous un marcelo weis fait pour
finir on va parler du ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume puisque
bien didier guillaume est ce que c'est
un atout important pour emmanuel macron
face à ce monde agricole on ne sait que
didier guillot il connaît l'agriculture
il est plutôt appréciée des agriculteurs
bah déjà un sens de la communication
beaucoup plus marqué que celui qu'avait
son prédécesseur et stéphane travert la
cette campagne sur eux contre la grippe
à xining la ghriba chine c'est plutôt
futée puisque sara lee tous les
agriculteurs c'est bien fait c'est un
homme de communication il connaît très
bien
par ailleurs c'est un pragmatique qui se
définit d'ailleurs comme atrocement
pragmatique donc sur la par exemple il a
il a fait des sorties sur sur le vin
qui sont pas forcément bien vue des
milieux de la santé mais côté
extrêmement bien apprécié des milieux
viticoles
c'est quelqu'un qui qui a qui est un élu
de la drôme c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
bien ces sujets là est effectivement là
il ya un effet changement de casting qui
commence à avoir ses premiers effets à
le mot de la fin avant de se quitter une
dernière image en du président de la
république en direct qui vous le voyez
poursuit sa visite visite qui sera
longue on va les suivre bien sûr toute
la journée sur public sénat prochain
rendez vous à 16h30 avec delphine girard
merci à tous les trois à d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous donc à 16h30
pour la suite du salon de l'agriculture
sur public sénat
[Musique]
je